Ja, es gibt jetzt Rush, allerdings wirkt es ein bisschen übers Knie gebrochen, ich habe
vorhin schon zwei Runden gespielt.
Werdet ihr aber gleich sehen.
Wohin die Legacy Features auch gefixt, du meinst Scoreboards, na natürlich nicht, natürlich
nicht.
Keine Battlefield 2042 Musik, ja weil das Spiel ja auch so viel Musik hat.
So, kurz was trinken.
Achja, falls jemand am Start ist, gucken wir, ob da Captain Poggers oder irgendwer noch
ankommt.
Ansonsten machen wir irgendwie einen Squad, weil das Game macht tatsächlich, ist am erträglichsten
wenn man, finde ich zumindest, mit Leuten zusammenspielt.
Cower Range, was Cower Range, was für ein Ding, Prime Sub, danke für den Sub, auch
wenn ich nicht weiß, wie man es ausspricht.
So, ach Ranger, ach jetzt verstehe ich es, alles klar, Massive Exquisite Name, das ist
es.
So, es gibt angeblich neue Skins, über die sich alle aufregen, die muss ich mir gleich
mal angucken, wenn ich in Game bin.
Gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit Limit Menu FPS, hat das ein Setting dafür?
Kencap FPS, ne, Menü FPS zu cappen wäre tatsächlich gut, weil im Menü lag es, Moritz
willst mitspielen?
Ne, du musst bestimmt Valorant-Stellz machen, oder?
Falls du das mal installiert hast, Lul.
Hm, was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade sagen, ach ja, Menü FPS Limitieren wäre natürlich
äußerst Pog, weil ich kann das Spiel jetzt noch nicht mal starten, weil es im Menü so
viel Leistung zieht, wenn ich noch was anderes zeigen will, das ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Zumindest, ich zeige euch mal die Patch Notes, Patch Notes.
Und was ich auch witzig fand, ist das hier, also im Prinzip das, was ich auch schon gesagt
habe, wenn man uns Steam Stats, übrigens soll ich euch mal das Highlight erzählen.
Ich sag jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen Dice, natürlich nicht irgendwie eine aus Schweden
direkt, sondern die Agentur, mit der ich, ich muss vielleicht mal den Sound ein bisschen
leiser machen, ich glaube so ist gut, also die Agentur, mit der ich die Battlefield 2042
Sponsorings gemacht habe, also die quasi so, nehmen wir mal Dice vertreten hat zu mir
gegenüber, was ja nicht wirklich stimmt, aber ihr wisst was ich meine, die hatten wohl
den Auftrag bei den Content Creators nachzufragen von Dice Feedback zum Spiel und die hatten
wirklich die Nerven mich zu fragen, ob wie ich Battlefield 42 finde und wie viel besser
das jetzt mit den Patches geworden ist und das fand ich schon irgendwie lustig, weil,
also nicht so als hätte ich da nicht eh schon zig Videos drüber gemacht oder so, zumindest,
ich hab langsam echt das Gefühl, die haben immer noch nicht ganz verarbeitet, dass ihr
Game suckt.
Ich glaube wirklich, dass die teilweise noch denken ihr Game ist geil.
Zumindest, ich hab halt einfach geschrieben, so ich geh eh davon aus, dass sie nie wieder
was mit mir machen wollen und ich sag ihnen jetzt halt einfach mal wie es ist und da hab
ich halt mal geschrieben, was Sache ist, ja gut, dass die nix mehr mit mir machen wollen,
kann ich dir erzählen, mit der Agentur würde ich gern was machen, die war nett, die haben
das alles gut gehandelt.
Soll ich euch vorlesen, was ich geschrieben hab?
Ich kann euch vorlesen, was ich geschrieben hab, also jetzt mal Namen und so, außen,
vor, außen vor gelassen, ich lese euch vor, was ich geschrieben hab, ich hab mich wirklich
großartig geflammt, ich hab halt einfach gesagt, wie es ist mit dem Game, Feedback Battlefield
2042, ich hab gesagt Moin, dann der Name von meinem Ansprechpartner, also die ursprüngliche
Anfrage war ja, es geht darum, wie sich das Spiel entwickelt hat, was euch in welchem
Stadium des Games gut gefallen hat, nach Patches, vor Patches, vor Release, nach dem ersten
Patch, Launch, Early Access und was nicht gut war und so zum Thema Spielerlebnis, Langzeit-Motivations-Server,
wo die, ja, genau, ja ich hätte ihn einfach mal im Video, zumindest hab ich geschrieben
Moin, gut, dann werde ich mal Klartext reden über Battlefield 2042, ich gehe eh davon
aus, dass DICE mich nach meinen Videos als Creator nicht, wenn man irgendwas dabei haben
will, gehe ich jetzt tatsächlich aber von aus, alles andere würde mich wundern, ich
mein, ich hab das Game so hart geflammt, aber die soll eigentlich, ganz im Ernst, eigentlich
dieses bescheuert, Kritik sorgt ja eigentlich dafür, dass es besser wird, aber das will
ja heute keiner hören.
Also, da hab ich geschrieben, erster Punkt, dank dem Trailer war man richtig gehypt und
hat ein Battlefield erwartet, dass es sich auch wie ein Battlefield anfühlt, zweiter
Punkt, Maps zu groß ohne Details, Siege of Shanghai sah vor Jahren besser aus und hatte
mehr Details als heute 2021, Kaleidoskop, Größe und 128 Spieler zählen für mich nicht
als Ausrede, dann lieber kleinere und feinere Maps und weniger Spieler, wenn man das nicht
hinbekommt, in Conquest läuft man eben, Nächster Punkt, in Conquest läuft man ewig, ohne dass
was passiert und wenn was passiert, dann ist es direkt Clusterfuck, 128 Spieler, vor allem
Breakthroughs auf offenen Maps, sind einfach nur eine Linie, 64 vs. 64, vor allem auf Breakaway
und spielbar, für einen Gegner, den du siehst, seh ich 15 und gegen Kaleidoskop, erste Base,
Breakthrough im Haus, unten ist Metro 64 Mann, Kindergeburtstag, Nächster Punkt, viel zu
wenig Content zum Start, zwei Spielmodi in All Out Warfare, wo einer nicht mal ordentlich
spielbar ist, kaum Waffen, kaum Gadgets, kaum Fahrzeuge, kaum Attachments, obwohl man keine
Kampagne hat, mega viele Entwickler hatte und andere Games dafür liegen lassen hat,
warum ist XP im Portal eigentlich immer noch nicht aktiviert? Dass es Booster Server geben
wird, war mir direkt nach der Ankündigung klar, ja es gibt Rush, Nächste Frage, wo
ist das Scoreboard, warum gibt es keinen ordentlichen Server Browser oder wenigstens
Map Selection oder einen All Chat, warum sind das Legacy Features? Nächster Punkt, Battlefield
3 und Bad Company 2 spielen sich im Portal nicht wie Battlefield 2 oder Battlefield 3,
Nächster Punkt, Objectives auf Häusern, WTF, da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das noch mit einem
Patch besser wird, Nächster Punkt, Cutscenes und Force Spawns am Anfang der Runde, dazu
kommen Menüs, die kaum bedienbar sind, man kann Gegner nicht orten via Sound, allgemein
war Sound immer absolut bombastisch in fast allen Battlefields, in Battlefield 2042 nicht,
das Game hat nicht mal einen wirklichen Soundtrack, Hazard Sound begeistert zwei bis drei Runden,
danach hört es keiner mehr an, ich mag Specialists an sich, aber es ist halt wie vieles undurchdacht
nicht zu Ende durchdacht, zum Beispiel Maria Falk als Sniper mit Selfie und Ammo Box und
Motion Sensor, Portal ist ziemlich gut mit dem Rules Editor, wenn man da noch mehr Features
und Content einbaut, kann ich mir vorstellen, kann man damit echt was gutes bauen, Nächster
Punkt, Langzeitmotivation nicht vorhanden, sieht man auch am Trend der Spielerzahlen
auf Steam, zwei Drittel sind schon weg, das musste ich Ihnen nochmal unter die Nase reiben,
der Trend wird auf Origin und Konsole ähnlich sein, Apokalyptische Background Story passt
nicht mit Umsetzung in-Game zusammen, so das waren erstmal so meine Punkte, dann habe ich
geschrieben, ich finde die Steam Review und Metacritic Bewertung zwar etwas überzogen,
aber es geht in die Richtung, wie ich es auch einordnen würde, es ist eigentlich so viel,
dass man das jetzt alles gar nicht aus dem Kopf einfällt, von Bugs wie Hit Track rede
ich gar nicht, die sind durch die Patches etwas besser geworden, aber das Spiel hat
im Kern so viel undurchdachte Entscheidungen, dass ich schwarz sehe, ob da jemals was Gutes
bei rauskommt, allerdings ist mir mal wieder eine Sache bei den Events aufgefallen, 90%
der Creators sind einfach nur krasse Schleimer, die alles feiern, was man ihnen vorsetzt,
das ist sicherlich für vieles gut, wenn man einfach nur Hype aufbauen will und Werbung
machen, ist das sicher toll, aber ich hoffe nicht, dass man sich in Entwicklung auf die
Einschätzung dieser Leute verlässt, weil dann wundert mich gar nichts mehr, das Spiel
ist einfach nicht fertig und hat an vielen Stellen gute Ansätze, aber fast nirgendswo
zu Ende gedacht, hat natürlich nichts mit dir zu tun, ich würde mich freuen, wenn wir
in Zukunft bei anderen Sachen wieder zusammenarbeiten könnten, Gruß Max.
So, das war mein Feedback an DICE zu Belfin 2042, also wenn die sich danach immer noch
ein reensam geiles Game gemacht haben, dann weiß ich auch nicht, find's ja witzig, dass
die überhaupt Feedback einsammeln, ich mein, die müssen einfach Reddit lesen, the fuck,
was anderes schreib ich da auch nicht, achja, zum Wetter, zum Wetter hab ich ja gar nichts
gesagt, ja quasi, für die Agentur, die haben mich gefragt über diese Agentur, die da Sponsoring
vermittelt hat, ob ich mein Feedback zum Game abgeben kann, hab ich gesagt, ja, gut, wenn
ihr das wirklich wollt, dann mach ich das, das Feedback geht eh def 0, ja, ok, ich zeig
euch jetzt mal die Patch, achso, nee, was ich euch zeigen wollte ist folgendes hier,
das ist im Prinzip das, was ich auch bei SteamStats geschrieben hab, ihr müsst euch das mal anschauen,
es ist einfach zwei Drittel weg, sogar mehr als zwei Drittel und dann sagt ihr auch unser
Oberleakerboy, Playerbase has dropped 70% since launch und die Stonks sind auch getropped
um 18%, das haben wir letztens im Stream schon gesehen, sowohl Spieler als auch Investoren
sind nicht happy mit diesem Spiel, ja, da ist was dran, was hältst du vom Halo Infinite
Progression System, bisschen lattensam, an sich finde ich es, von den Unlocks her, hat
es halt wirklich coole Unlocks, halt viel Trash, macht es New World nach, ich weiß nicht was
dieses Jahr mit den Games ist, von New World bis Battlefield, von Cyberpunk, ach was, nee,
das gab, zumindest wir gucken mal ganz schnell in die Patch Notes, Notepads, das ist auch
so ein Ding, wird das eigentlich irgendwo im Spiel weiter thematisiert, außer dass ab
und zu mal eine Ansage kommt und dann Webster um die Ecke kommen kann, ich bin einst auf
den Mount Everest gestiegen, von dahin ging es immer nur bergab und dann ist es vorbei
mit Notepads und die Welt geht unter, ach du dachtest die New World Spielerzahlen, ja
die New World Spielerzahlen wo wir gerade dabei sind, einfach nur weil es Spaß macht,
ja, einfach nur weil ich es witzig finde, so ein Absturz, so ein Absturz, ich kann mich
nicht erinnern, ich muss das, ich muss das, das war so klar, das ist so überrasch, guckt
euch das mal an, fast eine Million und wupp, achja, es gibt natürlich, es gibt natürlich
auch die Leute, die sagen, Max, das ist doch normal, dass MMOs nach Release was verlieren,
ja natürlich, Steam Stats, Destiny 2, ich glaub, das ist ja nicht so außerhaltskräftig,
so Release ja gar nicht auf Steam war, naja, es geht auch Downhill, würde ich mal sagen,
das geht auch ziemlich bergab, Carlo, danke für den Sub, so, schauen wir mal kurz in den
Patch rein, bevor wir uns in das Vergnügen werfen gleich, ich hab übrigens gelesen, bei
diesen Spielern funktioniert die Maus nicht mehr nach dem Update, ist jetzt kein Witz,
die haben es geschafft, eines der Kernelemente in einem Spiel kaputt zu machen, dass man
nicht mehr auf Gegner schießen kann, also die Maus soll angeblich nicht mehr gehen,
aber wie gesagt, ich hab vorhin zwei Runden gespielt, bei mir gingen die Maus noch und
die Hitrack ist auch nicht gefixt, ich hab vorhin wieder richtig schön durchgeschossen,
die Steuerung ist Legacy, achso, ja natürlich, jetzt versteh ich das auch, also, Battlefield
2047 Update 3, No Pets, alles klar, damit meinen die uns, nehmen doch die Pfeil, das
erinnert mich daran, wo ich ganz am Anfang, als ich angefangen hab Half Life 1 zu spielen,
da wusste ich gar nicht, dass man strafed, mein Mikrofon knackst, wenn mein Mikrofon
knackst, dann werd ichs mal kurz abmachen, und, hast du was bei deinem, ne, Moment, hä,
Moment, Moment, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test,
Ne, das hört sich okay an, ne, Leute ich mach es mal kurz ab, ich mach das mal kurz ab
und 말을 es neu dran, das könnte hier dran liegen, so ich glaub, jetzt ist es besser,
Jetzt habe ich das mal entwirrt und die Verlängerung ordentlich hingestellt.
Danke für den Sub, ich weiß nicht, wer war es denn, Möb, Pog, DirectX Error, ja das habe
ich auch schon gelesen, dass es ein paar haben, bei mir geht es zum, also wichtigste Sache
in diesem Update, lass mal kurz durch, what's new, weekly missions, übrigens, man könnte
einfach so eine Liste machen, dann wäre es nicht so viel, wenn man das in, also es ist
ja nicht so viel, aber, also wichtiges, wenn man da eine Liste macht, ist man fünf Dingern
durch.
Insgesamt haben die tatsächlich relativ viel gemacht, Kleinigkeiten aber halt zum größten
Teil, also, weekly missions, ich meine, es gibt eh nichts zum anlocken in dem Spiel und
jeder, der regelmäßige Spiele hat, hat schon fast alles anlockt, also keine Ahnung, wo
der Sinn ist, warum es in Portal übrigens keine XP gibt, verstehe ich nicht, weil du
kannst auch gegen Bots einfach alle Attachments und so anlocken, also, kein Schimmer, zumal
man das ja auch ohne Probleme in Portal irgendwie beheben könnte, somit für jeden dritten Gegner
oder so, wenn die Gegner schwächer sind, was auch immer, ja Rush gucken wir uns dann gleich
an, so, also es gibt drei verschiedene Missionen, ich muss mal ein bisschen was trinken, ich
will so Hals drungen, ok, so, Missions, Portal gibt es jetzt Rush, das ist offizielle Playlist,
die kann man spielen, das ist eigentlich ganz nice, Custom Portal, Presets, juckt jetzt
nicht weiter, man kann im Rules Editor ein bisschen mehr machen, das ist ganz gut, dass
man sehen kann, was den Gegner gekillt hat, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, ja, es ist
eine offizielle Playlist über Portal, sieht man dann gleich, so, Quality of Life, du hast
aber auch schon seit Monaten, ja, ich weiß, vielleicht seid auch irgendwie hier, irgendwas
am Start, so, also, Improvements, Ben bitt, Dankeschön für den Sub, so, Quality of Life
Improvements, das Menü ist verbessert worden, man kann angeblich jetzt besser Freunde erkennen,
ok, es ist smoother, die Transition between Menüs und Matchmaking, ja wunderbar, Emily
Smile, eine Milliarde Euro, Dankeschön, huge Subscriptions hier, Pongers, Massive, ich
werde jetzt einfach mal meinen Subscriber Sound machen, weil ich kann nix anderes machen,
ich habe keinen Sound für Bits to Bit Donations, so, Gameplay, sie haben über 150 kleinere
Anpassungen an den Maps gemacht und angeblich ist es jetzt auch Audio etwas klarer zu hören,
müssen wir mal schauen, so und hier unten drunter gibt es detaillierte Patch Notes,
das wichtigste ist eigentlich, dass es jetzt Rush gibt und den Rest werden wir sehen, ich
starte das mal, ach so Leute, falls ihr irgendjemand von euch im Origin habt, dann ist es am einfachsten,
wenn ihr mitspielen wollt, sagt mal Bescheid, oder ich gucke einfach mal, wer ist denn hier
online, der Sirius Maxis am Start in den Weiten, Pongers ist auch da, ja, da weiß ich doch,
wen ich jetzt schon gleich in den Weiten werde, so und ich wundere Leute, im Menü ruckelts,
im Menü ruckelts, aber im Spiel ruckelts dann nicht, ach ja, übrigens das Knacksen,
wie meint ihr das Knacksen hier, das da, das ist, wenn ich mich mute, manchmal mute ich
mich, weil ich euch nicht ins Ohr husten will oder so, guckt ihr gleich mal den Weihnachts
Skin an, oh ja, stimmt, so nachdem es im Menü ruckelt, werde ich mal kurz was umstellen,
Game Capture an, Display Capture aus und in der Hoffnung, es Capturet jetzt auch Battlefield,
nicht Halo, Battlefield sollst du Capturen, Capture Battlefield please, Battlefield Capturen,
jawoll, weil so ruckelt es im Menü nicht, achso, Lautstärke, ich glaube so passt, alles
klar, den Skin soll ich mir angucken, Moment, Moment, wo sind die Skins überhaupt, hier,
Dor, nee, Collection, so Boris hat nen Skin, wo ist Boris, Boris hat nen neuen Skin habe
ich gesehen, nee, wo sieht man, wo sieht man überhaupt die neuen Skins, wo ist, wo ist
der Boris Skin, das ist nicht der Boris Skin, Boris, Boris, haben die den Boris Skin deaktiviert,
Boris Boris hat angeblich jetzt nen Weihnachtsmann, Weihnachtsmann Skin, ich weiß aber nicht,
ob das jetzt hier dabei ist, also angeblich gibt es, let it battle, they have it, die
haben es entfernt, Alter, da sieht man mal, was das für nen Kackladen ist, die sind so
detached von ihrer Fanbase, Alter, das ist nicht normal, ja, guck hier, so sah Boris
aus, gecommodet, gecommodet Weihnachtsmann Boris, ähm, was ich nicht so genau verstanden
habe, ich mein, der Skin ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so wahnsinnig geil oder so, aber warum wurde
der Skin dann jetzt so krass geshitstormt, das verstehe ich nicht, ach ihr seht mein
Screen nicht, lul, seck, hier, Leute, so sieht Boris, so gab es Boris, Boris Skin, warum
da jetzt so geshitstormt wurde, verstehe ich nicht, ich find den Skin jetzt nicht sonderlich
hübsch, aber so den Ultrashitstorm, weiß nicht, hier, gecommodet Weihnachtsmann halt,
ich mein, es ist ein bisschen billig, wenn man ehrlich ist, weißer Bart und einfach
hier so ein rotes Ding drum, aber was willst du machen, hat nichts mit Battlefield zu tun,
ja gut, ich glaube, das muss man sich bei dem Spiel eh abschminken, wenn es danach geht,
muss man die Hälfte aus dem Spiel entfernen, also deswegen, das ist eindeutig, das ist
ja das, was ich nicht verstehe, auf der einen Seite so krass apokalyptische Weltuntergangshintergrund
Story und dann Cringe-Sprüche und sowas, aber ich find's jetzt im Kontext, dass das
Game halt eh schon hart cringet, gar nicht so schlimm, ach ja, und es gibt einen übelsten
gecommodet Skin und dann gibt es, der andere ist sowas von Kikona, Leute, hell yeah, passt
mal auf, hier, äh, hallo, Moment, muss ich den anderen skinnen, weil Webster kriegt auch
nen Skin, Webster kriegt nämlich einen Cowboy-Skin, Freedom, Freedom-Skin, Portal Rush, doch
in Portal Rush gibt es angeblich EXP, ansonsten gibt's da nicht so viel, so, dann spielen
wir da ein paar Runden, würd ich sagen, machen wir kurz den Soundtrack aus, machen wir hier
die Capture, Display Capture, ne, Game Capture an, Display Capture aus, was ruckelt, kurz
Hauptmenü, zack, Rush, ach so, zack, und gucken, ob das hier stimmt, ähm, Maustastatur,
ich geh mal auf, hoffentlich hat sie sich jetzt gemerkt, Orbital Rush, bam, bababam,
gucken wir uns das mal an, jetzt bin ich echt gespannt, was dabei rauskommt, Leute, 300
FPS, das droppt eh gleich auf 50, aber gut, ach, ich hab niemand eingeladen, zack, ich
geh wieder raus, ich geh wieder raus, ich geh wieder raus, ich lad Captain Polgar Serious
Max und die, jaja, ich würd, ich würd gern raus, das wär nett, wenn das funktioniert,
kann man in, kann man einladen, wenn man in-game ist, ist das durchdacht, na, das M-Complacement
ist nicht so krass durchdacht, äh, Leute, ich kann nichts machen, ich kann nichts machen,
ich kann nichts machen, ja,
Warum sendet das 50.000 Mal Partyinvites gerade?
Error!
Probier'n wir's nochmal aus.
Jetzt geht's.
So, joint ihr jetzt bei mir mit rein.
Ach ja, ihr jointt bei mir mit rein.
Nice.
Okay, das scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Okay.
Okay, dann wollen wir mal, wollen wir mal rush.
So.
Einfach mal...
Alter.
Geht schon mal gut los.
So, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob alles flüssig ist, ob es irgendwie ruckelt oder sonst was.
Dann müssen wir gucken, ob der Captain Poggers reinkommt.
Ist der Captain Poggers drin?
Nee.
In Q?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
16?
16 vs. 16?
Sollte es nicht eigentlich 32, 32 sein?
Seid nach wenig FPS aus sehr gut, das ist ja in dem Spiel normal, dass es da nicht viel
FPS gibt.
Moment, ich bin Boris?
Was zum Teufel, ich will nicht Boris sein.
Äh, Captain Poggers, ich kann dich wiederinviten, falls es irgendwie Error gibt.
Ich spreche jetzt einfach...
Monkeys.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal mit gesprüht und gebetet.
In Q?
Ist doch auch schön.
Nee, du bist drinne.
Also wenn du in Q bist und es irgendwie Fehler gibt, sag Bescheid, dann entweide ich dich
wieder oder ich gehe raus, im Zweifelsfall.
By the way, einer der eben mit der Freund geschrieben hat, ich soll zum HNO Arzt gehen.
Wenn ich sage, hallo HNO Arzt, ich habe einen trockenen Hals, ich muss husten und hab gefühlt
und ich muss mich hier rausbanden, Zeug im Hals, dann sagt er hier, sind sie privatversichert?
Dann sage ich, nee, dann sagt er dann zu mir, ja dann nehmen sie sich einfach mal ein bisschen
frei und dann macht er nichts.
Wenn du hingehst und sagst, ich bin privatversichert, dann macht er erstmal 50.000 Untersuchungen,
dass du...
Alter, was ist hier oben los?
MonkaS, okay, ich muss aufhören zu sprühen, okay, Orbital erinnert sich irgendwie an
Arika Harbor, ernsthaft jetzt, ich mein, sowohl vom Setting als auch von der Vegetation und
so hat das nichts mit Arika Harbor zu tun.
Ich überleg gerade, was dich, meinst du, du meinst das, wo man nach der ersten Base
runterläuft in die Stadt, war das der Stream oder lag des Extremen, chat, das müsst ihr
mir sagen, lag das, lag das, wenn ich spiele, wenn es laggt, dann muss ich umstellen auf
Game Capture, es laggt, oder, sag mal, ich guck mal, ja, angeblich, mega bad, okay, da
müssen wir, da müssen wir Game Capture machen, Game Capture geht besser, wie ist der Server,
gar nicht, einfach die offizielle Rush Queue, hi, es ist Juhi, Dankeschön, Social sind
noch alle da, Rush, oh, jetzt sollte es flüssig sein, gibt's schon Mods, um die Katzen zu
skippen, nee, leider nicht, was für eine Auflösung, 1080p, also 1920 mal 1080, gibt's denn TDM,
ja, TDM gibt's aber nur in Portal, nur in Portal, hat jemand irgendwie super krasse
Geheimtipps gegen trockenen Hals und Schleim im Hals und sowas, irgendwie, was weiß ich,
Eukalyptus Dampfbad oder sowas, dann mach ich das, weiß ich auch nicht, schon, ihr habt
recht, ich bin schon wirklich Monate am Husten, Honig in heißer Milch, Wasser trinken, ich
sauf schon relativ viel, also, Wasser, alter Webster, dicker Sack, Penchel Honig, sehr
viel Sodbrennen, nee, ab und zu mal, wenn ich gar so viel gefuttert hab oder so, nee,
an sich, an sich hab ich eigentlich relativ selten Sodbrennen, ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
wo ich hin soll, ich eier jetzt hier auf dem Dach rum und kann eigentlich nix machen, Achtung,
wir machen jetzt mal was, nicht runterfallen, leiten voll Boost, ja, wachst du morgens auf
und hustest viel, ja, also nee, husten nicht, husten nicht, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab immer
ziemlich, muss mich immer ziemlich reuspern morgen, so nach dem Motto hier, ich hab dann
auch übel Schleim im Hals, muss dann irgendwie erstmal ne halbe Stunde, bisschen mich reuspern,
husten, dann ist wieder eigentlich alles in Ordnung, jetzt ist hier, was gibt das hier,
wenn es fertig ist, Chat, Chat, Chat analysiert Gesundheitzustand, so quasi jetzt hier, so
Remote, Remote Beratung, eine Stunde Review von Angry Joe, nee, wo sind wir hier, wo sind
wir, wo haben wir hier, geile Gegners, hätte ein Zwerchfelldurchbruch sein können, was
hat mein Zwerchfelld dann mit Schleim im Hals zu tun, Keg Wade, die Maps sind richtig gut
durchdacht, es ist einfach, es ist einfach mitten auf der Map jetzt hier Stopp, mitten
auf der Map ist jetzt einfach mal Stopp, es ist einfach mitten so ne rote, einfach rote
Linie, was war denn das gerade, kann mir das irgendjemand schlüssig erklären, wo ich mich
da gerade lang gezogen hab, drei Liter Mountain Dew, ach ja, stimmt, für MLG Scopes, MLG legit,
der Chat hier wieder richtig, richtig auf Zack, Chat weiß einfach Bescheid, vielleicht kommt
das auch von der Corona Impfung, man weiß ja nie, hatte ich hier noch rüber, nee oder
wahrscheinlich nicht, das ist nicht die beste Waffe für die Range, zumal meine Achtung,
also wenn ich mit der Waffe den Typ nicht kille, dann mit keiner, mach ein Corona, das
hab ich schon, ich hab kein Corona, bin ich auch ehrlich gesagt ganz froh, dass ich kein
Corona hab, so, wir stellen uns jetzt mal kurz hier runter, ah da hinten ist er, nein,
pass mal auf, wir wallbangen den jetzt, das geht mit der Waffe nicht, okay, man kann es
ja mal ausprobieren, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, auf einmal steht drei hinter einem, null.
Wird jemals wieder einer Corona bühr kaufen?
Nein, weil Corona ist pleite gegangen während Corona, kein Witz, müsst ihr mal nachgucken,
Coronapilz oder was das war oder wie in die Corona Brauerei als pleite.
Corona extra, nicht keine Ahnung.
Corona extra? Keine Ahnung. Hallo, ich möchte hier bitte switchen auf meine Motion Sensors.
Oh, da kommt aber einiges. Da kam aber einiges um die Ecke. Es gab doch mal den Witz, dass
die sich umbenennen von Corona Brauerei in Ebola Brauerei, weil das aktuell nicht so
vorbelastet ist. Irgendwann habe ich noch diesen Gag gelesen. Das ist natürlich wieder
richtig krasser Boomer Humor gewesen. Alter, meine Güte. Könnt ihr mal verrecken? Was
gibt es Neues im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel? Ich war seit jetzt zwei Wochen nicht mal im
Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel. Okay. Milch mit Honig. Ich glaube, das ist keine schlechte
Idee. Das mache ich. Chat weiß Bescheid. Wir wissen es doch immer. Im Prinzip rettet
mich der Chat doch schon öfters. Der Chat hat mir letztens auch wieder irgendwelche
Links gepostet zu irgendwelchen Patch Notes und sonst wie was. Der Chat weiß einfach
Bescheid. Ich glaube, das ist nicht die richtige Waffe für diesen Einsatzzweck hier gerade.
Wir müssen mal einen Motion Sensor dahinten hinhauen, dass wir irgendwie die Chance haben,
das zu bashen. Was? Okay, die sind alle down. Motion Sensor dahinter. Alles klar. Wenn wir
Glück haben, sehen wir auf der Map sogar was. By the way, Map nicht zoombar. Hat man sich
auch gedacht. Legacy Feature braucht man nicht. Wer braucht zoombare Maps?
Haben sie sich wahrscheinlich im Zoom Call überlegt. Lul. Pains Champ.
Muss jetzt hier um die Ecke. Ich dachte, da ist was, aber da ist nichts. Das Game ist
Trash oder? Ich würde das Game wirklich gerne gerne gerne haben. Ja, easy easy. Wer nutzt
noch Zoom? Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe Zoom noch nie verwendet. Aber wisst ihr was lustig
ist, was ich letztens gehört habe in einem Video? Ja, ist gut, weil ich letztens in einem
Video gehört habe. Die Cringe Sprüche müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken, dass es das
Zoom, dieses Zoom App Hersteller, dass die gar nicht an der Börse sind. Aber irgendeine
Firma mit Zoom im Name hatte den übelsten, hatte das übelste hoch, weil die gedacht
haben, das wäre Zoom Video. Also auch die Stonks Leute sind nicht so die cleversten.
Deine Info ist leider korrekt. Oh, Manifest. Nice. Nice. Mal gucken. Manifest hat finde
ich das größte Potenzial, ähm, eine gute Rush Map zu sein. Ist das Game mit dem Update
nun spielbar? Im Prinzip ähnlich wie vorher. Auch schon wieder Defender. Die M-Cops sind
mal richtig beschissen platziert, sagt der Captain Poggers. Warte mal ab. Warte mal ab
auf Renewal. Renewal hat die schlimmsten Amkoms, Leute. Wartet ab. Ich hoffe wir spielen
danach Renewal. Da könnt ihr euch mal angucken. Da könnt ihr euch mal die beste... Sir Serious
Max ist gecrasht. Kann das sein? Jetzt ist er wieder da. Du bist nicht mitgejoined. Was
ist denn hier los? Joint das jetzt? Oder nicht? Jetzt geht's. Okay. Was der Patch gebracht
hat, also jede Menge minimal Verbesserungen. Ähm, und angeblich 150 Änderungen auf allen
Maps. Kann man hier rüber? Oh, nice. Wobei ich da ehrlich sagen muss, naja. Ich kann's
noch nicht beurteilen, weil ich kaum Breakthrough bzw. Conquest gespielt habe bisher. Alter,
die Schneiber-Dudes, man. Habt ihr mitgekriegt, wie es einfach keinen Kill-Sound gab? Es gab
einfach keinen Kill-Sound, als der Typ mich weggeschneibert hat. Der kommt... Du kommst
hier nicht hoch. Keine Chance. Man kann ja auch nicht roppen oder so. Ich spawn rein.
Wir sind eh Defender. Das macht ja nix. So. Ach ja, übrigens auch eine Sache, die mir
direkt bei den M-Com Platzierungen aufgefallen ist. Die M-Coms sind jetzt so weit auseinander
weg. Du kannst also, wenn du am einen M-Com bist und am anderen M-Com geht die Post ab,
hast du eigentlich gar nicht die Chance da großartig irgendwie was zu machen. Weil die
so weit auseinander sind, müsst ihr euch meinen, also. Wo geht hier eigentlich gerade
was? Ist hier was? Sind die wahr? Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wo die Gegner stellzen.
Komm, wir gucken mal auf die Map. Die Gegner stellzen gerade Richtung A. Ach, wir sind
hier, ok. Wo ist denn hier was? Da hinten? Hab ich da was gesehen? Ich geh mal kurz hier
runter. Ach nee, hier gehts nicht durch. Ja, sehr. Gebatet. Wow. Gleich diffusen hier.
Diffuse-Champ. Ach guck mal, es gibt noch nicht mal ne Progress-Anzeige, wie man diffusst.
Oder? Doch, hier oben. Hier oben, stimmt. Doch. Hier ist Webster halt richtig. Oh, da oben
ist der Schneiber. Der Schneiber-Man. Guck mal hier. Ich hab übrigens falsch gedrückt,
ich hab hier aufgegangen. Wo sind sie hier? Wo ist sie? Wo sind sie? Irgendwo hier. Also
ich hör hier 50 Milliarden Schritte. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das Gegner sind oder
Team-Mates. Angeblich ist. Ah nee, ok, der ist down. Alles klar. Also hier mag ich halt
Webster, das ist richtig. Pega-Aim. Da haben wir das passende Emote für. Bist du auf dem
leeren Server? Nee, ich bin hier, guck mal. Ist eigentlich, eigentlich alles, alles voll.
Ah nee. Da oben, hier. Leute. Wartet mal, wartet mal. Mal gucken, ob das geht. Mal gucken,
ob ich irgendwie. Jawoll, gib ihm, gib ihm. Pippo, fett. Der muss abnehmen. Ok, das hat
jetzt nichts gebracht. Ich dachte, hier geht's irgendwie sinnvoll weiter. Spodermann, ja.
Richtig, richtig gespodert. Ok, das passiert anscheinend manchmal immer noch. Achtung.
Weg. Ich bräuchte ein bisschen Ammo. Ammo wäre halt nice. WTF. Pass auf, ich geh zum
Arzt und es ist dann doch ein Zwerchfall-Durchbruch, wie es der Chat predictet hat. Und dann sage
ich, Herr Doktor, ich wusste schon. Dann fragt er mich woher. Dann sag ich Twitch-Chat. Wow.
Twitch-Chat. Und dann wird mein Arzt sagen, ah selbstverständlich, Twitch-Chat weiß
bei so was ja immer Bescheid. Twitch-Chat ist ja bekanntermaßen richtig Poggers für
Diagnosen. Der weiß Bescheid. Und weil der ja auch bestimmt Twitch kennt. Ok, ich muss
mal kurz warten bis mein Crappling-Hook wieder da ist. Crappling-Hook, please. Äh ne, ist
alles da. Da, hier. Wo ist er? Wo ist er, der Dude? Kommst du her? Kommst du her? Nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein. Frau Diverse-Operator. So nicht. So nicht. Aha. Der Belegen. Legehände
macht er. Massive Legehände. Ich seh ihn schon da drauf. Zusprinten. Ich diffuse.
Ah fuck. Ich hab versucht eh gedrückt zu halten und, oh nice, nice, nice. Und dabei
die Gegner abzuehmen. Das hat nicht so genau, nicht so gut funktioniert wie ich mir das
vorgestellt. Es gibt keinen Progress-Balten. Dann sagt der Arzt, nimm diese Pillen und
du fühlst dich Poggers. Ja. Captain Poggers, ich komm gleich rüber sobald mein Crappling-Hook
wieder da ist und nicht wieder. Äh oder auch nicht. Jetzt, jetzt. Easy Rats. Die kriegen
uns nicht. Ist, wo ist denn der Dude? Ist der da oben? Der ist bestimmt da oben, hä?
Ja, da wollte ich nämlich auch hoch. Nice, da wurde er geschreckt. So muss es sein.
Woah, woah. Habt ihr das grad gesehen? Das hat einfach mal komplett, komplett geleckt.
Manifest spielt sich tatsächlich ganz gut. Manifest spielt sich, Rush, in, in der Tat.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Da sind sie. In der Tat ganz brauchbar. Muss, muss, muss ich echt,
muss ich echt mal anerkennen. So Containerstellen können sie. Wo war der? Ah, der ist down.
Okay. Ey, wisst ihr was ich übrigens auch in so, in so jedem Shooter richtig, richtig
Big Brain finde? Wenn die einfach irgendwo random Explosivfässer hinstellen. Ich mein
Chat, das würdet ihr bestimmt auch machen. Also stell dir mal vor, stell dir mal vor,
ihr seid verantwortlich für Defense, für die, für die Defense-Stellung hier so in
so einem Hafen. Dann würdet ihr bestimmt auch sagen, Moment, das erste was wir machen
müssen ist, lasst mal ein paar Explosivfässer hinstellen. Obviously. Oh, nice. Okay, diffusen
können wir natürlich vergessen mit dem Pence-Man daneben. Nee, jetzt, jetzt. Pence-Man, auf,
Diffuse-Stells, Diffusors, Diffusors. Ah, okay, gleich abprobieren. Ja, geh ruhig was
vor, da kannste nichts mehr mitmachen. Übrigens, falls einer noch mitspielen will. Oh, wir
haben es. Easy, easy won. Ich, ich dachte die haben grad gelegt. Sind wir, sind wir top,
top Squad? Pence-Champ. Maps sieht sehr Defender-Favorite aus, ja. Viele, viele Maps sind äußerst unbalanced
und die M-Coms auch sehr Pence-Champ. Ach ja, fünf Hipfire-Kills, na klar. Das war das
wichtigste, was man hervorheben muss, ganz klar. Rundenzeit 51, stand da wirklich 51
Minuten? Hab ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen. Wenn man übrigens Glück hat, sucht das danach
gleich ein neues Match. Poggers Hipfire-Kills. Ja, wie wir ja wissen, Hipfire-Kills sind
ja prinzipiell das allerskilligste überhaupt. Und überhaupt nicht easy. Ach, das ist Restzeit,
okay. Ich frage mich, wann das Legacy-Feature-Scoreboard kommt. So, wen haben wir denn hier noch?
Wen kann ich denn jetzt noch adden? Lass mal kurz, lass mal schnell rein. Eingucken. Irgendjemand
da, den ich enden kann, der mit spielen will. Also Chat, wie sieht's aus? Irgendwelche
krassen Battlefield-Auner bei euch am Start? Zwei, also wir haben einen Squadplatz auf
jeden Fall noch frei und temporär zwei. So, was haben wir hier denn jetzt? Defender auf,
was ist das jetzt? Ist das Orbital? Ah ja, Defender Orbital, okay. Ja, Webster-Stells.
Wisst ihr, dass ich, ich muss das noch mal sagen, weil das sagen die Leute immer so,
ich kann nur das Game haten oder so. Ich finde die Operator-Geschichte immer noch nicht schlecht
und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das richtig gut hätte funktionieren können, wenn
es, oh, da kommt was Fettes. Das ist nicht richtig in das Spiel integriert und nicht
richtig durchdacht, aber ansonsten ist das wirklich cool. Du kannst Webster nehmen für
Mobility-Stells, du kannst zum Überbrücken Sundance nehmen, du kannst, wenn du einfach
nur viel aushalten musst, Maria Falck nehmen. Das ist schon richtig, richtig nice und du
musst hier in dem Spiel noch nicht mal die Gegner one tricken, also die Operator, Mercy
Main by the way, one tricken. Nee, du könntest hier auch richtig gut wechseln, weil die haben
jetzt ja auch nicht so die Wahnsinns-Tiefe oder so, ja. Hallo, ich möchte dich retzen.
Ah, nice, wurde schon gerätzt. Oh, der Pen-Span ist da. Nee, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Hast du die MP9 mit AI gegrindet? Teils, teils. Ich habe am Anfang ein bisschen AI-Kills gemacht,
den Rest habe ich in-game an. Oh, oh, oh, oh, ich bin am Zaun hängen geblieben, super.
Das Trommelmagazin habe ich aber unlocked mit ganz normalem Spielern. Aber MP9 kannst
du ja gar nicht spielen am Anfang mit 20 Schuss. Du musst mindestens Dreier, du musst
mindestens dieses 30 Schuss-Magazin anloggen, ansonsten ist es ja komplett umsonst. By the
way, Orbital finde ich, ist jetzt an der Stelle gar nicht so Defender-favorisiert, aber ich
glaube wir sind einfach besser. Ich wechsle mal rüber, mal gucken, ob da auf der anderen
Seite was geht. Wie viele Spieler in Rush? Ich glaube, das ist 16 versus 16, wobei ich
mir einbilde, vorher wäre das 32, 32 gewesen, aber wahrscheinlich habe ich einfach nur nicht
richtig geguckt. Ach, hier geht es nicht weiter, ok. Dann kann man ja eigentlich nur an diesem
Berg abcampen hier. Vielleicht sind die Server auch unterschiedlich, weil das wirkte deutlich
kontrollierbarer als vorhin. Ist das wirklich 16? Ja, dann habe ich mich vielleicht vorhin
verguckt, das sind dann wirklich 16, 16. Wobei ich sagen muss, 16, 16 ist auch mit Abstand
vielleicht noch 24, 24 das beste für Rush, meiner Meinung nach. Alter, wie ich den weggesprayt
habe. Der Semmel, ja, ihr könnt mitmachen, ihr müsst mir bloß euren Origin-Namen schicken,
dass ich euch enden kann. Ah man, Motion Sensor. Also wir haben ein permanentes Squad noch frei.
Ah nice, man kann jetzt auch, ok, das finde ich gut, man kann jetzt auch im ausretzen,
das ging in anderen Battlefields glaube ich nicht. Konnte man, konnte man in Battlefield
4 Leute wiederbeleben in der Off-Zone? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube das ging nicht. Wahrscheinlich
ist das hier aber gar nicht gewollt, sondern nur ein Bug. Venbit hat geschickt, Leute ihr
müsst es nochmal schicken, ich bin ja mitten im Game. Schickt es mir am besten noch mal
nach der Runde. Wir machen jetzt die Runde fertig und dann machen wir gleich noch nach
der Runde invite ich noch welche. Aber ich muss nachher, wenn der Captain Poggers wieder
kommt, also wir haben nur einen permanenten Squad-Slot. Ok, das wirkt jetzt hier wirklich
sehr defender heavy, aber vorhin habe ich mega auf den Sack gekriegt auf Orbital, also ich
glaube das ist gar nicht so defender heavy wie man denkt. Wow, das war das. Voll vereimt
aber ich habe ihn trotzdem noch gekillt. Dich würde die tatsächliche Entwicklungszeit
von dem Game interessieren, mich auch und ich glaube, dass die Entwicklungszeit so in zwei
Phasen eingeteilt werden kann. Das erste ist, wo man noch gedacht hat, man macht einen Warzone-Konkurrent
und dann hat man quasi festgestellt, oh fuck wir machen da doch einen Battlefield raus
bzw. der Hazard-Zone alleine trägt nicht oder was auch immer. Und das war die eigentliche
Entwicklung, also die eigentliche Entwicklung war wahrscheinlich ein Jahr oder so, nein
nicht ein Jahr, war wahrscheinlich so zwei Jahre oder so was, eineinhalb bis zwei Jahre
und davon am Ende der Teil dann auch noch das mit der Entwicklung, wo man gedacht hat,
man macht einen Warzone. Das ist gerade ziemlich unfair. 1,5 Jahre für Portly, ja so würde
ich es ausschätzen, 1,5 Jahre. Man hat angefangen quasi einen Warzone-Konkurrent zu programmieren
und dann hat man gesagt, wir machen doch einen Battlefield raus, deswegen wirkt auch der
Battlefield-Aspekt so roh und die Operator an sich ja doch relativ durchdacht. Der Pantsman
ist da hinten, was macht der hier? Der soll mal da weg. Der Pantsman, ich glaube der ist
da unten oder? Ich habe nach gelernt, das ist halt das Ding am Trommelmagazin, das dauert
ewig. War weg ist Rush für etwas, das kann ich schlecht sagen. Bisher hatten wir sehr
einseitige Runden. Grappling-Hook nach unten, ja das geht tatsächlich ziemlich gut. Das
habe ich in der Beta schon festgestellt. Übrigens, passt mal auf, wenn ihr denkt ihr
bekommt Fallschaden, könnt ihr einfach Grappling-Hooken und dann ist der Fallschaden dann weg. Also
man muss sich einfach nur, wie das halt in echt auch so ist, einfach nur mit einem Grappling-Hook
nach unten crappeln und alles ist gut. Riechtiger Five Head, High IQ Play. Guck mal, da ist er
da und jetzt gehe ich da mal rein. Der Typ musste noch nicht mal das Target wechseln,
der ist einfach auf dem Turm geblieben und dann bin ich eigentlich, BAM Headshot, dann
bin ich eigentlich, BAM Headshot. Aber der Captain Pongas ist schon wieder da, also
Leute einen kann ich noch in Walten fürs Squad. Einer geht noch. Warum haben wir nur 5 von
11 geplaced, wir haben die übelst gereckt. Verstehe ich nicht, aber ok. So, dann schauen
wir mal. Fatal, dich kann ich gerne in Walten, wenn du am Start bist. Ach du bist einfach
so gejoined, Pongas, Pongas, Pongas. So, das heißt wir sind jetzt 4 Stück, sehr gut,
in Rush. Geruscht wird jetzt. Die Skins gerade waren hässlich, ja es gibt eigentlich kaum
schöne Skins. Guck mal, ich muss sagen, ah ok, zu spät, aber oh Breakaway wieder, BAM,
ich muss sagen, ich merke in Rush wenigstens so ein bisschen eine Struktur in dem Game,
wo man halbwegs einschätzen kann, wo Gegner sind, das finde ich schon mal ziemlich gut.
Ansonsten Maps sind halt immer noch nicht sonderlich geil und das M-Complacement ist
auch ziemlich, wenn man durchwachsen. Guck mal, jetzt sind wir Attacker. Die hier gehen
tatsächlich sogar noch. By the way, wisst ihr, dass das DICE gemacht hat, was ich gesagt
habe in meinem Video? Ich habe gesagt, man könnte richtig gut 16 versus 16 und 32 versus
32 Maps machen aus unterschiedlichen Gebieten der 128 Mann Maps, weil es schnell und easy,
billig Content bringt. Und da hat sich DICE natürlich gedacht, ah wenn der Max da sagt,
dann machen wir das. Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob das jetzt auch wieder, es ist tatsächlich
16 versus 16. 16 versus 16, Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie angenehm ich das finde,
dass es endlich mal sich nicht so, nicht so, nicht so mega Clusterfuck mäßig spielt.
Ha, fuck, ich wollte ihn outmove, ich dachte, ich heile mich und gehe dann wieder hoch,
bis er runterspringt. Die stellen mich irgendwann ein. Ja, ich glaube, das letzte, wo ich arbeiten
will, ist in Schweden bei DICE. Okay, nicht das letzte. Das letzte nicht, aber eines
der letzten Sachen. Das erste Mal hier im Stream, ja nice, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden
hast. Lass mich spawnen, Leute. Spawnen, Opa, ich kann einfach hier spawnen. Sack. Wo ist
er? Okay, ich retze euch, ich retze euch. Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich komme dahin. Also
eins muss man ihn auch lassen, das Hedgehog Geräusch finde ich immer noch nice. Warum
spielst du ohne Visier? Weil ich, der Chat hat es gut erkannt, auch weil ich ein Ironsight
Enjoyer bin. Hat nicht funktioniert. Ein richtiger Ironsight Enjoyer bin ich. Seems legit. Ich
weiß auch nicht, woran es liegt. Ich spiele nicht in jedem Game zwangsläufig Ironsights,
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde es in diesem Game tatsächlich am angenehmsten.
Schwer zu sagen, warum. Ich wollte eigentlich auf das Dach. Oh Mist, ich dachte, ich komme
noch runter, ohne mich hinzulegen. Ja, das war dumm. Battlefield 4 hat ja auch nice Ironsights.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich glaube, ich habe in keinem Battlefield bisher großartig Ironsights
gespielt, aber in dem Game weiß ich auch nicht, was es ist. In dem Game muss ich sagen, Ironsights,
Poggers. Nice hat was Gutes gemacht, die Ironsights. Ja wisst ihr, Fatal ist wieder raus, ist bei
dir gecrasht? Kannst einfach wieder rein joinen. Moment, Captain Poggers ist ja gar nicht drin.
Ich habe den Captain Poggers doch eben im Chat gesehen. Wow, der ist komplett explodiert
der Kerl. Gehen wir mal auf die andere Seite. AEK, ja die AEK war richtig nice. So, flank,
flank, stellts. Ok, das war es, das ist ziemlich dumm. Hier komme ich jetzt nicht mehr richtig
raus. Da kommt gleich eine, Achtung Leute, ich sage es euch. Mensch, wenn ihr einfach
sterben. Ok, für die Range ist die Waffe auf jeden Fall nicht gedacht. Gibt es jemand
unter euch, Chat, der den Unterschied erkennt am Fadenkreuz, was Single und was Burst ist?
Das ist das Burst Fadenkreuz, das ist das Single Fadenkreuz. Ich erkenne es nicht am
Fadenkreuz. Also man hat jetzt hier unten rechts auch eine Anzeige, das ist auch neu.
Ich habe mich mal switcht. Ich bin auf die Pistole gemusst. Ist Rush gut? Also ich muss
sagen, die Aimcoms sind nicht gut platziert und die Maps Eiken sind immer noch nicht,
aber dadurch, dass es eben kein totaler Clusterfuck ist, finde ich das bisher tatsächlich am angenehmsten.
Lasst mich in Ruhe Leute, ich bin Ironside Enjoyer. Alter, Pepega Aimed. Richtig heftig
Pepega Aimed. Habt ihr das gesehen? So Pepega, keine True Pepega Aimed. Und dass man immer
diese Overlay hat auf der Map ist auch doof, dass man da nichts sieht. Jagt ihr gleich
die Corona Impfung noch rein hier? Eine Runde Booster. Da gehe ich jetzt nicht raus. Das
ist auch für Ironside Enjoyer nichts hier. Wackeln der Kamera. Das kann man ausstellen
mit dem Wackeln der Kamera. Ich bilde mir auch sogar ein. Ich habe das ausgestellt,
dass die Kamera so krass wackelt. Wir rollen drüber, nice. Ich habe Breakaway noch nie
gewonnen hier. Also ich habe Breakaway noch gar nicht als Attacker gespielt. Wo geht hier
was? Motion Sensor rein. Alter, das war der gar nicht. Der hat aber gut drauf gezogen
hier. Wenn es der war, den ich gesehen habe, aber das war der nicht. By the way, Hinleg.
Alter Tür. Geh auf Mann. Lege Henne. Habe ich es noch? Ich habe es noch. Jetzt muss
da einer reinpushen und dann. Oh, Südkorea ist am Start, Leute. Ah, defused. Wie ging
noch mal der Trick bei Hetzner, damit man das ein bisschen günstiger bekommt als die
vorgefertigten Angebote. Du musst mein Code einlösen. Ausrufzeichen Hetzner in Chat.
Du musst einfach mal ein 20 Euro Startguthaben Code einlösen. Easy. Kannst du quasi einfache
Server drei Monate betreiben? Was genau hittet mich? Das war eine dumme Idee, Leute. Es
war eine richtig dumme Idee, auch für Ironside Enjoyer. Nice. Aber sind das alles Headshots?
Warum mache ich noch zu viele Headshots? Headshot Enjoyer würde ich sagen. Das geht
am besten mit Ironsides. Nein, Schwachsinn. Geht natürlich mit Red Dot und so ganz genauso.
Charlie Mike. Was für krasser Militärslang ist das? Charlie Mike. Ich kenne Oscar Mike,
das heißt On Move oder sowas. Was ist denn Charlie Mike? CM. Keine Ahnung. Schon den
Weihnachtsmannskin freigeschaltet. Nein, da wurde er entfernt, wie es aussieht. Wir
wackeln einfach mal ein bisschen rum. Pass mal auf, Trick 17. Oh man, meine geilen Crappling
Moves funktionieren nicht. Continue Mission. Alter, die Leute sind wieder so Sixhead hier
im Chat. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Warum habe ich eigentlich so ein extrem high IQ Game? Bist
du dir sicher, dass ich den gekillt habe? Ich bin gestorben, noch bevor ich den überhaupt
richtig abschießen konnte. Aber wenn das Spiel sagt, ich habe den gehetschottet, dann
habe ich den gehetschottet. So, jetzt können wir uns richtig nice hochtrappeln. So war das
nicht gedacht, aber ok. Angel, Angel did it again. Da kommt was von hinten. Oh nice,
wir haben es, ok. Ich habe ein bisschen Schiss, ehrlich gesagt. Feinderkennung ist einfach
so genial in dem Game. Du siehst immer sofort, wer Freund und Feind ist. Ich glaube, das
war euch auch absolut klar gerade. Kann das sein, dass wir die richtig heftig überrollen?
Hallo, mein Spring geht nicht. Ich kann nicht mehr springen. Mein Springbutton ist kaputt.
Einfach denied. Ach, der Springbutton war kaputt, weil ich in einer permanenten Springanimation
gelockt war. Verstehe. Seems legit. Kriegt man im Portal wieder XP? Also zumindest in
der offiziellen Playlist wie Rush kriegst du noch XP. Oder kriegst du, kriegst du XP.
Easy win. Was soll ich sagen? Kann dazu nur sagen, ich bin einst auf den Mount Everest
gestiegen. Seit da ging es nur noch bergab? Diese Sprüche. Ich frage mich immer noch,
wer sich bei DICE gedacht hat, dass das eine gute Idee ist. Painschamp, aber richtiger
Painschamp. Damals warst du auch ein Abenteuer, aber dann ein Feind ins Knie. Gut, das ist
ja schon... Das kommt aus Zeiten, wo Leute noch auf YouTube Fussroda Collections gemacht
haben. Das ist ja schon komplett 2014 oder so. Oder noch früher. Ach, der geht direkt
weiter einfach. Game vorbei, bam, nächstes. So mag ich das. Was macht eigentlich der
Captain Poggers? Ist das Spiel jetzt spielbar? Warte auf ein 30 Minuten Video mit einem Update.
30 Minuten kann ich da nicht wirklich drüber machen. Ich mach wahrscheinlich ein Video
über Rush und sag, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass es immer noch am wenigsten Clusterfuck
hat und ich deswegen Rush aktuell auch bevorzuge. Ich muss echt sagen, Rush ist... Du musst
hier nicht permanent ultra auf Zack sein. Und wisst ihr, was lustig ist, dass ein einfacher
Modus wie Rush und weniger Spieleranzahl das Game einfach instant besser macht. Wo man
wieder sieht, dass die Idee mit 128 Spieler und dann noch Breakthrough und Conquest Only
keine gute Idee war. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass hier auch wunderbar Domination oder Smaller
das Conquest funktionieren würde. By the way, Fallschaden geht weg, wenn man hier so
Sprungstellens macht. Was vollkommen logisch ist. Battlefield Physix. Bashen, alter, bashen.
Motion Sensors. Toll. Hier unter mir geht ordentlich Spaß. So stelle ich mir das mit
dem Movement vor und es ist auch richtig nice, wenn du mal nicht von 50 Ecken abgeaimt wirst.
Okay, das hat er gut gemacht. Neue Waffe in P9, ist die auch OP? Keine Ahnung, die war
schon immer ziemlich gut. PP29, da sind wir kein Fehler dabei. Moment, wie? Steppen
wir. Wir müssen attacken, wir müssen nicht defenden. Ich habe mich gerade zubaden lassen
von der Ansage. Am geilsten finde ich immer noch den Ansage auf Kaleidoskop, Let's the
Base Breakthrough. Wenn er sagt, we are winning, just take the objective. Gut, dass du es gesagt
hast, wäre ich so überhaupt nicht drauf gekommen. Oh nice, ich kann dich nicht retzen, du bist
in der Wand. Das ist anscheinend immer noch drin als Bug, wenn man in der Wand steckt,
dann kann man nicht wiederbelebt werden. Zählen den Portal nun mit Rush auch auf die Kills
mit den Attachments? Ja, ja. Wir können mal kurz switchen, dass wir schneller da sind.
Ich finde es übrigens auch sehr nett, dass sie uns spawnen auf dem Kran, dass man mit
seinen Specialists auch ordentlich was machen kann. Aber da sieht man, Manifest ist tatsächlich
auch als Rush Map ganz okay. Bisschen defender heavy, ja, aber es ist wenigstens mal eine
ordentliche Map. Da oben wird abgecampt, man. Da habe ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet. Okay,
wir gehen hier wieder als Wrapling-Hook-Stelzmann rein. Oh, was ist das? Warum habe ich da auf
einmal Raketen? Ich habe Raketen, finde ich nice. Bin mir zwar nicht so ganz sicher, was
ich damit machen soll, aber ich habe Raketen. Und Raketen sind ja bekanntlich immer nice.
Wie schießt man mit diesen Dingern überhaupt? Ne, da bin ich zu dumm für. Ich kann nicht
aussteigen, Leute. Meine Aussteigen-Taste ist broken. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ah,
ich bin aber lang, ich bin rangeslided. Vielleicht mit Quick-Revive. Welche Grafika? Ich habe
1080 Ti. Oh, Stelz-Action, Leute. Ja klar, LMG legit, man, mit LMG. Ich auch, wie viele
auf 100 FPS kommen, alles auf Low-Stellen, alles auf Low. Leute, wir müssen jetzt gewinnen.
Only Wins. Oder auch nicht. Only Wins. Komm ich da irgendwie rauf? Leute, ich habe gedrückt.
Ich habe gedrückt, aber manchmal funktioniert das nicht. Ach ja, ohne es ist 16 vs. 16.
Just take the objective, easy. Just win. Just win, wissen wir, das ist doch ganz einfach.
Doch alles easy. Ich glaube, wir sollten einfach jetzt rüber flenken, sodass die uns gar nicht
krass abstelzen können. Dass man jetzt, oh fuck, jetzt ist er down. Ihr könnt bei mir
Sponsoren gleich. Oh, wir haben nur noch 12 Artikel, fuck. Na dann. Dann war das wohl
auch keine so schlaue Idee von mir jetzt. Aber B ist auch ziemlich offen. Oh nein. Okay,
wir haben noch 6 Tickets. Komm ich hier rüber? Ah, nice. Okay, seriously. Oh nee, da steht
ein Pantsman daneben, fuck. Der Pantsman ist am Start. Wir machen es jetzt, Leute. Vergiss
es. Okay, dass die Defender einen Panzer haben, ist natürlich unglücklich. Da machst du
nix. Porgas ist wieder da jetzt. Vierer Squad, easy wins. Nur noch easy wins ab jetzt. Problem
ist nur, wir haben keine Tickets mehr. Also vielleicht doch. Oh, oh, oh, okay, das war's.
GG Eats. Oh, danke für den Sub. Ja, Kali rechse ich auch so. 128, einfach. Okay, ich
rechse auch. Diese Sprüche sind so schlimm. Ja, also, wie gesagt, für einen Gegner, den
du siehst, 10 durch 10, das ist blöd. Und da sieht man wieder, wie viel besser sich
das Ganze jetzt schon spielt. Einfach mit weniger Spieler auf bisschen engeren Raum
und dann ist es schon viel angenehmer. Leider ist wahrscheinlich Rush kein wirklicher, soll
ich sagen, so Kerngedanke von denen in dem Spiel. Deswegen werden die wahrscheinlich
am M-Complacement gar nicht so viel machen mehr in Zukunft. Die sagen jetzt, ah, hier
habt ihr Rush und alles ist gut. Doch es gibt Helis in Rush, kommt auf die Maps an.
Es gibt Helis. Ich glaube, hier auf Orbital hast du, glaube ich, ab der zweiten Base ein
Heli. Wart's mal ab, es gibt Helis auch in Rush. Aber gut, du hast jetzt nicht so dieses
ultra gestellte da mit fünf Helis, fünf Jets und sonst was, wie in Conquest, was ich persönlich
als Infanterie-Spieler aber auch gut finde. Ja, stimmt, auf Breakaway hatten wir auch
eben den Heli. Ach guck mal, das merkt sich jetzt ja sogar, ob man Burst-Modus hat oder
nicht. Sag mal, Max, kann das sein, dass bei dir immer beim Start der Runde, dass ein
wenig rumbackt? Wir gehen direkt auf B, auf B sind meistens wenige Gegner. Was? Alter,
ich hab den mit der MP9 aus nächster Nähe reingerotzt. Ist absolut broken, okay. Gut,
der hat aber eine Armorplate gehabt. Und ich konnte mich nicht bewegen, weil ich eh drücken
musste, geplanten. Planten und aimen auf Gegner ist eh so ein Ding für sich. Sollen wir mal
gucken, wie krass die Defender-Helvi das ist? Schauen wir mal. Wir hauen jetzt erstmal
da einen Motion-Sensor rüber und gucken, was da abgeht. Okay, viel geht da ab, viel. Guck
mal, da drüben steht schon der nächste. Jetzt nächster Motion-Sensor rüber, alles klar.
Au, von wo, Mann? Oh nee, rechts. Wurde was an der Performance gemacht? Ja, es sind jetzt
16 vs. 16 Spieler nur. Krieg ich einen Rats? Ja, auf jeden Fall, nice. Heute Big Brain Rats?
Ja, oh nee, nee, okay, das ist in dauernd. Ist der Ram-Leak gefixt? Nö. Ist immer noch,
ich kann nicht aussteigen. Ist immer noch nice in Memory Leaks. Jetzt! Lege Henne! Jawoll!
So, ich camp mir jetzt hier einen ab, Leute. Massive-Camp-Stellz. Ich mach hier wirklich
dem Ultra-Stellz, wie hieß er? Ah, ich hab vergessen, wie hieß mein Ultra-Stellz-Video-Typ?
Das gibt's ja nicht. Jetzt hab ich den Namen tatsächlich vergessen. Black Ops 1 Havanna,
wie hieß der Typ denn? Ihr wisst's doch, Chet, ihr wisst's doch, ich mein. Der, der
Ultra-Stellz? Nee, wie hab ich, der Ultra-Skiller, der Ultra-Skiller war das. Ja, genau, nicht
der Ultra-Stellz oder der Ultra-Skiller. Wie, haben die defused? Was ist hier los? Keg-Waite?
Ach nee, A haben sie noch, okay. Ich hab das Gefühl, in Battlefield ist es so, umso weniger
M-Coms die Gegner haben, umso schwerer wird's, weil sich alles konzentriert auf dem M-Com.
In dem Fall geht es aber, weil's ja halt nur 16, was das 16 ist. Guck mal hier, guck
mal hier, pass auf, jetzt will er einen Wegstellzen hier oben. Guck's euch an. Nicht jetzt. Wie
sie rumschreit, die Alte, äh. Sag mal, können die mal, können die mal please sterben? Alle
haben so Panzerplatten oder sonst was. Da muss jetzt mal, guck mal, da muss jetzt mal
richtig gebashed werden hier. Beide armor, ja. Obwohl ich schon mit der, mit der, mit
der MP9 die beste, beste Nahkampf, also mit, mit die beste Nahkampfwaffe hab. Bin die
K30? Was sagt ihr Leute, MP9 oder K30? Also quasi Vektor, Vektor oder MP9? Nein. Alter,
ich check nix mehr hier. Vektor, äh. Für die hab ich noch gar nichts frei gespielt.
Oh, oh. Nein, ich will dich retzen, man. Okay. Jetzt mal so ne Ammo-Kiste, wär nice. Cap'n'Poggers,
komm mit, auf geht's. Oh. Jetzt hätt man den Halo Master Chief Move machen können,
ranziehen, ranziehen und voll in your face. Meine Güte, was geht denn hier ab? Muss mich
verpissen. Okay, jetzt müssen wir ran. Oh, von der Seite. Also, ich muss sagen, ich fand
das gar, also ihr habt's ja gesehen, wir haben übelst dominatet als Defender und die geht's
als, ich hab' vorher ne Runde gespielt Offstream und hab' richtig auf den Sack gekriegt. K30
Extended Trump, ich hab' noch für die K, ich hab' noch gar nix, gar nix, oh, oh, hier,
da muss ich rein, da muss ich rein, rein hier. Gib ihm. Okay. Pants, man. Oh nee, dieses
Raketending. Raketending ist ja recht stopp, Achtung. Nein, du sollst da nicht hochklettern,
Alter. Pepo Fett. Oh. Ich bin ein wenig exposed. Nein. K30 Extended Trump. Okay. Die Sache
ist die, was eine dumme Werfe. Die Sache ist die, ähm, ich kann jetzt keine, ich kann
jetzt keine K30 freispielen, weil das dauert ewig. Da müsste ich, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich
so ne 20 Minuten, 20, 30 Minuten Runde gegen Bots machen, dann hätte ich's freigespielt.
Wir müssen mal, weil das Spiel keinen Soundtrack hat, wie euch auffällt. Das Spiel hat ja absolut
keinen Soundtrack. Machen wir mal ein bisschen was Gescheites an. Was gefällt dir beim Patch
bisher am besten? Ja, dass Rush dabei ist. Rush ist POG. Also ganz ehrlich, alles, was
nicht 128 ist, ist eigentlich POG. Ich, ich muss sagen 1616 ist okay. Ich denke 2424 hätte
man auch machen können, oder? Aber man hätte die M-Coms besser platzieren müssen. Hier
sind nämlich die M-Coms teilweise relativ weit auseinander. Gerade am Anfang.
Mir ist nicht mehr aufgefallen, dass keine Musik läuft. Ja. 32 Rush, ja, aber nur Custom.
Die offizielle Playlist scheint mir 16 versus 16 zu sein. Was ich aber auch gut finde, weil
es einfach mal kompletter Kontrast zum üblichen Battlefield Clusterfuck ist.
Nachdem man in dem Spiel eh keine Schritte hört, kann ich die Musik einfach anlassen.
Obbei, nee, ich mach die Musik aus. Das mach ich, das, das, das. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch
das auffällt. Irgendwie mach ich das öfters. Ich bin da, ich sag was schneller als ich
im Kopf denken kann, weil ich hab das total oft festgestellt, dass ich sag, ah, ich mach
jetzt das und ich sag dann quasi im gleichen Atemzug danach, ach nee, doch nicht. So als
hätte ich es überhaupt nicht richtig durchdacht. Also hab ich ja auch nicht. Ob, ob, ob, obviusli.
Nicht durchdacht. Wenn ich Glück habe, wenn ich, oh, Poggers. Der Captain Poggers ist
am Start. Hol ich. Alter, okay. Hier voll im Kopf. Nee, war gar nicht im Kopf. Aber wenn
wir Glück haben, können wir hier krassen, nein, nein, nein, ich hänge fest. Nicht jetzt,
genau, so sieht's aus. Nicht jetzt. Nicht jetzt. Ack. Jetzt haben noch zu viel gekonkt.
Spielst du Borderless oder Vollscreen? Ich spiele, was hab ich hier eingestellt? Gute
Frage. Ich hab Borderless glaube ich eingestellt. Ja. An sich ist, also in jedem anderen Game
außer Battlefield wäre ich mir da auch sicher, dass Vollscreen besser ist. Theoretisch zumindest.
Praktisch spürbar, eigentlich selten. Nee, der Unterschied zwischen richtigem Vollscreen
und Borderless ist halt, Borderless läuft halt noch über den Windows Composite Manager,
die heißen das unter Windows. Windows Dings Windows Fenster Renderer. Und Vollscreen macht
das Game halt selbst. Was theoretisch picken schneller ist. Alter, können die mal sterben
please alle. Oh oh, oh oh, oh oh. Alter. Für das, dass es 16 vs. 16, es geht hier
ganz schön gut was ab. Ne, DWM. DWM heißt das ja. Was ist denn DWM? Desktop Window Manager
oder was ist das? Oh nice hier. Hogger Spawn im Auto. Sehr schön. Äh, das hat ja gut
funktioniert. Oh oh. Da kommt gleich noch was. Ja okay, jetzt war aus. Jetzt war zu viel.
Jetzt war die Schürze aus. Das sieht man aber in dem Spiel, du brauchst unbedingt mit
viel Schuss. Diese ganzen Waffen mit 20 Schuss oder so sind komplett flusslos. Kannste eigentlich
gar nicht verwenden. Also Chat, ich hab meine Zweifel, dass das Game in einem Jahr keine
Bugs mehr hat. Das hat in einem Jahr wahrscheinlich andere Bugs. Ja, ein Poggers. Nein. In drei,
in drei Jahren ist das nächste Battlefield raus. Guck mal, da liegen sie rum und machen
nichts. Oh nice Flank. Massive Sixhead Flank. Bester Flank aller Zeiten. Bester Flank EU.
So und jetzt gehen wir aufs Dach. Bevor wir irgendwas machen, wir gehen jetzt aufs Dach
und aufm Dach campen wir uns richtig, richtig schön ein. Mit einem Spawn-Beacon und allem,
aber ich hab kein Spawn-Beacon. Nein. Alter, das ist mir zu viel hier gerade. Ich kann
euch nicht retzen Leute. What? Von wo? Warum spielt er immer die gleiche Waffe? Ich spiele
überhaupt nicht immer die gleiche Waffe. Ich spiele gerade MP9, weil MP9 für Close Quarters
Situationen richtig Poggers ist. Richtig nicer Spawn hier. Ach, durch die Gitter schießen.
Pass mal auf, wir meinen es. Sixhead Rats. Ja, gut, was solls sein? Ey, will mir irgendjemand
erzählen, das Game hat kein Skill-Base, Matchmaking, null. Was war das denn jetzt? Pepe Pepe Pepe
hat uns gekillt. Pepe Pepe Pepe war es. Pepepepepega. Wichtige Schwit- Nein, chat. Alles klar.
So war das nicht geplant, ich wollte eigentlich aufs Dach. Gibt es mittlerweile ein paar
weniger Bugs? Ja, das kann ich bestätigen, es gibt weniger Bugs. Also es gibt von 5000
Bugs drei weniger. Alter, mann, was ist denn hier los? Spawn down, Spawn down. Richtig
schwitze Action angesagt hier. Ahja. Angel did it again. Rinshtime. Dazu kann ich nur
sagen. Ein extrem großer Paints-Champ. Das Game hat nicht zu viel CPU-Lust oder so. Guck
mal, ich kann nicht mal das Fenster resizeen richtig, ohne dass es ruggelt. Pedalfield 1.
Oh Leute, Renewal. Guckt euch an, die M-Coms hier sind so abfuck gesetzt. Passt mal auf,
das sind die schlimmsten M-Coms, die ich bisher gesehen habe. Renewal M-Coms. Je nachdem,
es ist eigentlich egal, was man spielt, aber die M-Coms sind wirklich Paints-Champ. Guckt
es euch mal an. Die anderen, muss ich sagen, bisher, Hourglass war auch Paints-Champ, die
haben das Gespür dafür, die schlechten Maps nicht wirklich besser zu machen. Aber die
M-Coms auf Renewal, die sind wirklich richtig brain dead. Gefreiter daf, schön, dass du
eine Wege hergefunden hast. Oh, ich hab noch nie attackt, ich hab noch nie attackt hier
auf der Map. Vielleicht ist es ja aus Attackersicht besser, aber aus Defendersicht sind die M-Coms
richtig blöd. Richtig blöde. Ich leg jetzt, ich mach jetzt keine Lege hin, ich geh jetzt
aufs Dach. Ne, ich mach doch. Ok Leute, ich mach doch. Oh, mit dem Fenster sind 50.000
Gegner, lull. Kegway, Messer ins Gesicht, Mann. Alter, ich hab, ich hab, ich weiß überhaupt
nicht, was hier gerade abgeht. Terminated. Irgendwas, irgendwas hat mich gekillt. Ich
weiß nicht mal, was mich getötet hat gerade. Monkeys. Ich brenne. Warum brenne ich? Meine
Güte. Der 37-jährige Boomer muss es mal wieder richten hier, ich seh schon. So Leute, jetzt
geh ich aufs Dach. Dachstellts, mir egal, was hier mit M-Coms abgeht. Dachstellts. Nein,
lass mich in Ruhe. Fuck. Ich wollte aufs Dach hoch. Ist der Chat nach wie vor Team Only?
Ne, Squad Team Party, also ja, ja Team Only. Ich kann nix machen, sorry, ich kann dich
da nicht retzen, wenn ich retze, dann bin ich. Fuck, Mann. Ne, ich stecke hier in der Wand,
ihr könnt mich nicht retzen. Schreckt. Oh ne, wir müssen, müssen wieder ran. Erstmal,
erstmal alles, alles wegsprallen mit der Minigun. Oh. Ich würde, ich würde gern was treffen.
Boris, man. Boris. Okay, ja, ja. Rennt ihr nur rein, rennt ihr nur rein, keine Probleme,
easy. Rennt ihr alle nur in meine Minigun. Ist schon in Ordnung. By the way, ich hab
8 oder so gekillt, wir sollten doch jetzt eigentlich da rankommen, oder? Oh nice, wir hams. Oh fuck,
was ist denn hier los? MonkaS, Alter. Ist das, ist das 16 vs, ist das 16 vs. 16? Wie
geht denn das? Das ist ja, das ist ja schlimmer als Battlefield 3 Revive Train, Mann. Null.
Oh fuck, MonkaS. Ich hör 50 Gegner um mich drum herum. Ich kann nämlich nicht bewegen,
es geht nicht. Es ist nicht möglich mich zu bewegen. Okay, wir müssen Seitenwechsel
machen, Leute. Wir müssen Seitenwechsel machen. Sagt euch. Sagt euch, oh, oh, oh, oh, da kommt
ein Auto. Richtiges Schwitzer Gameplay, Mann. Jetzt richtige Schwitzer Gameplay, Leute, ich
sag's euch. Ich muss aufs Dach. Ich muss aufs Dach. Wenn ich aufs Dach komm, dann können
die bei mir spawnen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Okay, GG, Leute, ihr könnt, ihr könnt
bei mir aufs Dach. Ich hab jetzt, ich hab keine Muni mehr, aber das passt. Ich glaube,
hier kommt auch gleich was hoch, hä? Ich bin halt nicht der Geilste so vom Dach da jetzt,
aber haben wir irgendwie. Boris, wie geht das geht? Also falls ihr rein spawned, wären
so ein paar Kästen ganz gut. Ammo Boxes. Oh nee, jetzt muss ich nachladen, Mann, jetzt.
Oh nice, Ammo Box Wars, Ammo Box Wars. Oh, die Pog Box ist da, Leute. Oh, das, okay,
jetzt können wir easy Defenden, Leute, easy Defenden von hier oben, easy Defenden. Oh,
wir sehen's nicht. Scheiße, wir sehen's nicht, Mann. Aber wir können die, wir können die
ran gehen. Okay, Pepega aimed, richtig Pepega aimed. Aber die kommen nicht ran so. In der
Ask shoot it. Motion. Oh, von hinten. Nein. Aber zum Glück haben wir noch mehr Leute hier
oben. Einer müsste noch leben von uns, oder? Eh, shit. Aber wir haben's, wir haben's, Pog.
So, pass mal auf, die nächsten M-Coms sind richtig, richtig hängen geblieben. Wir können,
wir haben nämlich, guck mal, hier sind die M-Coms und wir haben komplett High Crown auf
dem Dach. Das ist richtig dumm. Oder auf der anderen Seite ist einer. Das vorher war natürlich
selbstverständlich kein Headshot. Also das war richtig Pepega hier. Vielleicht aber auch
nur, weil SBMM mich gegriffen hat. Mensch, lasst mich in Ruhe. Okay, es ist doch nicht
so Pepega, wie ich's gedacht hab. Also, das letzte Mal war das mega easy. Alter. Vielleicht
darf ich auch Glück. Aber die müssen sich halt mit dem Dach beschäftigen. Die müssen
sich halt mit dem Dach beschäftigen, deswegen. Ah ne, wir haben hier nichts zum retzen. 26,
was hab ich denn da alles gebashed? Ach, das war, ah ja, doch. Das war die Geschichte
mit der Minigun, ne? Die Gegner sind richtig gut, man. Was ist denn hier los? Das ist ja
gar nicht, das ist ja gar nicht so easy, easy durch Garage. Jawoll, machen platt. Oh, da
hinten sind noch mehr. Nein. Ah, ich warte mal. Pepegas, da sind zwei Stück dahinter.
Da machst du nix. Das ist bestimmt SBMM, Leute. Ich sag's euch. Das ist SBMM.
Okay, der flankt mich jetzt von links, ich sag's euch. Okay. Achtung, big brain time.
Ey, wo? Alter, wo kommst du schon wieder her? Wo kommt der schon wieder her, man?
Hansjürgen40plus möchte nicht gebashed werden. Weißt du, das schlimmste ist, dass Hansjürgen
von 37plus gebashed wird hier gerade. Das soll er sich halt einfach mal anstrengen.
Was? Wie krass die Gegner auf einmal sind. Ganz ehrlich, ich hab Renewal bisher nur erlebt
als easy mode Deluxe für die Attacker. Das ist mir richtig neu hier, dass man... Oh,
bockers. Richtig guter Spawn. Jawoll. Big brain time. Massive brain, Alter. Massive brain.
Okay. Aber trotzdem, trotzdem. Nice, nice, nice spawn. Max, du bist nicht der normale
Boomer-Zocke, eher ein guter. Ja, da bin ich froh. Wenigstens irgendwas muss man ja können.
Wogegen das restliche Team schon mal gar nichts kann. Captain Poggers, das ist mega schwitzig.
Wir gehen nach der Runde auch raus und suchen uns eine neue Lobby. Sorry. Geht ja nicht
anders. Ich sage, SPMM ist hier angesagt. Ja, was denn jetzt? Wie wärs mal mit sterben,
oder? Okay. Oder auch nicht. Aber Massive Revive, Massive Revive. Jetzt aber. Gib ihm.
Lege Hände. Alter, die Jumpshotten mich schon. Was ist hier los, wenn das nicht SPMM ist?
Die Jumpshot, nein, schon rein, Mann. Kack, wait, Alter. Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet?
What the buck? Du spawnst bis down. Einfach just win. Just win, Leute. Just take the
objective. Einfach das objective taken. Ist doch easy. Just take the objective. Wir müssen,
der Ansager, der Ansager sagt doch schon was sagt. Just take the objective. Hier geh ich
nicht lang. Mann, Alter, die Gegner, was geht mit denen ab? Was geht denn hier ab? Ich meine,
die sind schon ziemlich gut, die Runde, ja? Es gibt keinen Rang in dem Spiel. Zumindest
keinen Rang, der angezeigt wird. ESL, Mensch, toll. Wir suchen mal neu, Leute. Wir suchen
mal neu. Ja, das ist ESL Scrim. Was war das hier wieder? Ich such mal neu. Ich kann leider
nicht raus, weil wir uns die tollen Outro-Sequenzen anschauen müssen. Vom Gegner, der hatte S003
Rang. Hä? Was der hatte als Level S003? Vielleicht war es ein Hacker? Vielleicht war das ein
Hackerlobby? Das kann ja durchaus sein. Vielleicht war das wirklich ein Hackerlobby? Ich würde
es nicht ausschließen, dass das nicht schon geht. Garantiert, das ging wahrscheinlich
zur Beta schon. Ach so, das ist nach Level 99. Okay. Ist normal, dann habe ich nichts
gesagt. Guck mal. Ich habe ein Reward Unlocked. So, suchen wir mal die nächste. Wobei, Zack,
Zack, wir warten ganz kurz, wir warten ganz kurz, dass die ganzen krassen Schwitzer schon
ein anderes Game haben. Ich würde sagen, es lohnt sich für 40 Euro. Ach, ist das schon
runter gesetzt oder was? Gibt es das im Sale jetzt schon? Also, wenn es das jetzt wirklich
schon im Sale gibt, dann ist das ziemlich klar. Sie wollen Verkaufszahlen, Chebaten,
also auf Key Seiten. Wasch. Leute, ihr könnt mich doch jetzt nicht alleine spielen lassen.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wen ich da gerade noch hinweitet habe. Also angeblich wart ihr alle
noch drin. Jedes Game halbes ESR. Ihr habt es eben gesehen. Die haben mich gejumpschottet.
Wo kommen wir denn bitteschön dahin? Der hat einen um die Ecke gejumpschottet. Das
ist normalerweise was, was du hier nur siehst bei irgendwelchen Ultra-Call of Duty-Schwitzer-Lobbys.
Ihr seid doch alle da. Oh, Hourglass, Leute. Hourglass hat mich auch nicht überzeugt. Da
müssen wir jetzt mal was annehmen. Komm, wir gucken mal, wie die PP 29 jetzt ist. Langer
Lux. Passt. Ironside-Enjoyer-Anstart. So ultra verziehen tut die doch jetzt eigentlich
auch nicht. Hast du schon den Bober-Skin gesehen? Den haben sie doch wieder aus dem Spiel entfernt,
dachte ich. Hier geht's schon wieder los hier. So, B sollte eigentlich secure sein. Oh, der
Pantsman ist am Start. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Der macht Legehähne. Und nix wie weg. Aua.
Ich dachte, man kann sich vielleicht hier hochhucken, aber nee, kann man nicht. Das
ist 16 vs. 16. Nicht 12 vs. 12. Oh, shit. Ach, du kannst einem deine Meinung zu dem
Game abgeben in der Mail. Poggers, mach das mal. Die bekommen da bestimmt sicherlich nur
von allen Seiten sehr, sehr nette Mails. Warte mal, es wird ein ESL-Match angesagt jetzt.
Oh, die haben A gelegt. Legehähne ist am Start. Die Legehähne. Wie kommt der Dude denn jetzt
auf einmal hinter uns? Guck mal, wie die jumpen alle schon. 16 vs. 16 Fahrzeuge. Ja, es gibt
nicht viele Fahrzeuge. Hier auf Hourclass gibt's jetzt ein bisschen mehr. Normalerweise
hast du entweder gar keine Fahrzeuge oder halt jede Menge Jeeps und ab und zu mal irgendwas,
was anderes. Wo ist denn B? Monkeys. Ich check überhaupt nicht, wo hier was ist. By the way,
Leute, seht ihr die Wahnsinnsliebe zu Detail in diesen Gebäuden? Sieht halt aus, als hattet
es einen Mapper erstellt in einer Viertelstunde. Ich habe beim besten Willen keine Ahnung,
wo überhaupt was los ist hier gerade. Da hinten ist irgendwas los. Außen, da. Voll in Scatter
reingesprungen. Scatter. Das hat Twitch wieder was, was sie muten können in meinem Bot. OK,
das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach, mit dem Ding was zu hitten mittlerweile. Die haben
sie doch ganz gut genervt. Richtig ESL-Game wieder. Sieht aus, wie prozedural generiert.
Find ich auch. Gerade auf, gerade auf, gerade auf our class. Boah, Monka. Nee, hier geht's
gar nicht. Geht's hier rum? Hallo, Game? Haha, out of map, Lul. Aber ich glaub, wir haben
gleich gewonnen. Ich krieg zwar diese Runde absolut nichts geschissen und ich weiß gar
nicht, wo was abgeht, aber immerhin, immerhin. Oh, ich glaub A. Ich glaub, die machen Lege,
Henne. Oh, oh, der Pants-Man. Das war dumm. Du bist gespannt, wie sich Rush spielen lässt.
Ja, so wie du es hier siehst. Ziemlich ESL-Scrim-mäßig. OK, also ich bin grad wahnsinnig überfordert,
weil ich keine Ahnung hab, wo hier überhaupt was abgeht. What the? Achso, das war nicht
der. Ich wollt grad sagen. Was ist denn hier grad los, man? Das ist wirklich, das ist ja
härter als irgendwelche, wie gesagt, irgendwelche ESL-Scrims oder sonst was. Zumal ich absolut
nicht einschätzen kann. Oh, das ist das Boris-Geschütz. Ey, what the fuck, man? Meine Elo ist zu hoch,
ja? Sieht so aus. OK, OK. OK, Freund, Feinderkennung, Pork. Irgendwo ist doch hier angeblich was.
Irgendwo ist doch hier was. Wie kommt man denn jetzt hier aufs erste Level? Hier, oder?
Aber hier ist nix mehr. Ich glaub, wir haben's, Leute. 11. Poggers. Wir haben's gleich geschafft.
Ich hab nichts gemacht außer einen Kill, aber Serious Max und Captain Peng haben's gecarried.
Ich versuch euch zu retten, Jungs. Ah, Tür zu. Null. OK, der ist im Treppenhaus, der Typ.
Ich dachte, der sitzt hier unten rum. Ah, da oben kam er. Habt ihr gesehen? Jetzt kam
er an die Treppe runter. Gibt es etwa wieder ein Scoreboard? Nö, natürlich nicht. Ein
Scoreboard. I'm just better than anyone else. Beleuchtung hat das Spiel indoor gefühlt
gar nicht. Was hab ich denn schönes gemacht? Squadmate Revived. Mindblown. Gab's Performance-Änderungen?
Tja, gute Frage. Es läuft nicht besser oder schlechter als vorher. Die einzige Sache ist
als 16 vs. 16. Das ist ein bisschen flüssiger. Gab es von Seiten Dice eine Begründung für
das nicht vorhandene Scoreboard? Ja, es ist ein Legacy-Feature, haben sie gesagt. Was?
Oh, Kaleidoskop, das hab ich noch nie gespielt. Also hier, Rush. Sie haben gesagt, es ist
ein Legacy-Feature. Warum? Was sie darunter verstehen, weiß man nicht. Aber es ist ein
Legacy-Feature. Was auch immer. Keine Ahnung. Müssen wir mal in Schweden anrufen. Gelne
Sys? Nein, ich würd's mir jetzt noch nicht kaufen. Das Spiel hat im Prinzip auch mit
Update 3 noch alle Probleme, die ich in meinem Video angesprochen hab. Nur, du kannst sie
quasi ausplanten, wenn du ein bisschen 16 vs. 16 spielst. Aber selbst da merkst du
am M-Complacement und an den Maps, dass das einfach nicht so wahnsinnig gut durchdacht
ist. Ja, links und rechts schauen mit der Maus ist definitiv ein Legacy-Feature, deswegen
geht das bei manchen Leuten nicht, weil's abgeschaltet wurde. Das war ja so, ne? Also
ich weiß nicht, inwieweit ich das mitgekriegt hab. Ähm, der, die, also Maus-Look war Disabled
oder beziehungsweise Verbackt bei einigen Leuten. Maus-Look ist auch eindeutig ein Legacy-Feature.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo der Typ ist. Ich schmeiß mal ein paar Mal, oh, da kommt
was. Aha. Oh. Okay, jetzt hab ich ein Problem. Ich seh nix. Alter, wie die aimen! Was geht
mir den ab? Das ist, wie gesagt, ESL-Match 2.0. Ich komm aus dem Rauch raus, der Typ zieht
instant rechts auf mich rüber. Krasser Scheiß hier wieder, ey. Nee, nee, rett's mich nicht.
Hier oben rennen auch Gegner rum. Aber ich glaube, es geht jetzt. Ich glaube, es geht.
Ich mein, hier haben wir, hier haben wir denke ich ganz gute Chancen. Das ist halt wieder
eine wahnsinnige Pains-Champ-Posie. Einfach alles offen. Nein. Ah, wir haben Panzer und
die Angreifer nicht. Okay, dann haben wir schon mal gewonnen. Moment, das ist... Achtung,
Achtung, pass mal auf. Extrem 6-Head-Play. So was geht nur in 16 vs. 16, Leute. Überall
anders ist es nicht möglich. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo sie sind. Wo sind sie denn? Wo sind
sie denn alle? Das war klippwürdig. Ah, einer nur. Hätte ich die Zweite erwischt, dann wäre
das richtig progg gewesen. Oder drei sogar. Auf der anderen Seite, niemand will, niemand
will irgendwelche Highlight-Montage-Szene aufs Battlefield, glaube ich. Meint ihr Leute,
würden sie sich auf YouTube irgendeine coole Highlight-Montage angucken? Also, Montage,
insofern einfach nur die besten Clips, so 10 Minuten hintereinander geschnitten. Ich
glaube, das hätte am Ende 8K-Aufrufe oder so. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Nur Fail-Compilation.
Battlefield-Clips gehen nicht. Die einzigen Battlefield-Clips, die gehen, sind Bug-Compilations
und sowas. Das geht nicht. Okay, ich glaube, die Runde haben wir easy, Leute. Doch keine
ESL-Lobby. Die haben wir easy. Musst du gar nichts machen. Ich renne jetzt einfach mal
kurz in die Gegner, weil ich gucken will, wie weit man hier rennen kann. Sinnigerweise.
Ja, bis hier. Ich meine, das ist auch Werder. Guck mal, das ist einfach nur offen auf der
Map. Was hat man sich denn dabei gedacht? Ja doch, die Map favoriert eigentlich extrem
Defense. Guck mal, es ist einfach komplett offen. Ohne, dass du irgendwie eine Deckung
hast. Was sollen die Gegner dann machen? Ich guck mal, ob es irgendwelche Attacker-Wege
gibt. Ich schau mal kurz. Also, die Attacker könnten glaube ich ganz außen lang flenken.
Okay, das würde vielleicht funktionieren, aber das ist auch komplett flach. So, das
ist komplett flach. Die könnten hier 30 Kilometer aus und lang flenken und dann 30 Kilometer
übers Feld auf A rennen. Das wird keiner freiwillig machen. So. Ansonsten können sie vielleicht
noch Fahrzeug-Fights gewinnen. Okay. Hier ist nichts mehr. Hier geht es glaube ich nicht
weiter. Der Tunnel ist glaube ich komplett out of things. Ja, okay. Also, das ist wirklich
nicht so clever gemacht. Not five head. Oh nein, die haben gelegt. Die Legehänne ist
am Start, Leute. Ich will es jetzt nicht verlieren. Hacke ich noob. Ich habe mich getroffen. Richtig
dumm. Three Head. Iron Sight Enjoyer. Aber ich glaube, wir diffusen. Vergleiche das mal
mit der Mario Rush Karte, wo es auch einen grünen Park gab am Anfang. Was? Mario Kart?
Was? Ach, nicht Mario Kart. Metro. Warum habe ich Mario Kart gelesen? Das ist denn mein
Gehirn. Mein Gehirn setzt schon komplett aus. Metro Rush. Ich habe Mario Kart gelesen, man.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, wenn man nur mit einem Auge auf den Chat guckt. Ja, das
stimmt. Guck mal, da ist er wieder. Der will wieder gebashed werden. Nein. Nein. Nein.
Von allen Seiten. Hat das Update die Performance verbessert? Nee, das sieht nur so aus, weil
16 vs. 16 ist anstatt 64 vs. 64. Okay, die haben es tatsächlich geschafft, das Ding
in die Luft zu sprengen. Wir defenden jetzt einfach. Die haben bloß noch sieben Tickets,
oder? Oh, die legen B. Okay, wir machen den Dance, den Rush Dance. Jawoll. Rush Dance
ist erfolgreich. Hä? Wo ist der Dude? Ach, Wind. Battlefield Top Plays. Ich hätte selbst
genug coole Plays. Aber wie gesagt, Battlefield 2042 Sachen will keiner sehen. Das einzige,
was richtig gut läuft, ist irgendwelche Bug-Compilations oder so. Oder halt, du bist der mega Highlights-Channel
und machst es zu mehreren Games. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Battlefield-Only-Highlight-Channels
irgendwie da groß reingehen, was Subzahlen und so angeht und Aufrufe. Hat das Update
irgendetwas gerettet? Naja, im Kern hat sich eigentlich nichts getan. Es ist aber Rush und
das Gute ist noch nicht mal, dass es Rush ist, weil M-Complacement und die Maps sind
immer noch nicht gut. Das richtig Gute ist, dass es 16 vs. 16 ist und eben kein Clusterfuck
64 vs. 64. Das ist eigentlich das Beste daran. Da sieht man mal, dass so Battlefield im Kern
eigentlich ziemlich unverwüstlich ist. Egal, was man dem Game antut. Wenn du so ein paar
Parameter richtig einstellst, geht's. Und ist im Prinzip immer noch eigentlich ganz
okay. Und jetzt überlegt euch mal, wenn es schon so unverwüstlich ist, wenn man jetzt
einfach noch was richtiges und was Gutes und was Big Brain zusammenpassendes macht, dann
könnte das ein richtig geiles Game werden. Aber Battlefield 2042 wird es nie wieder werden.
Also ich meine Battlefield an sich nicht Battlefield 2042. Battlefield 2042 wird glaube ich nie
irgendwie ein super herausragendes Game werden. Auch wenn sie gesagt haben, sie planen das
zu supporten für Years to come, ich habe da so meine Zweifel. Serious Max hat wieder
Probleme, die Lobby reinzukommen, weil Battlefield. Okay, hier müssen wir jetzt. Alter. Nein.
Wo ist denn der Dude? Ach, der ist unter mir jetzt. Ist der da drin jetzt schon oder
wie? Okay. Ich hätte den warten sollen. Ich hätte warten sollen, bis der Rest nur um
dann beide zu killen. Die sind gut im. Die sind nicht nur gut im Zeitplan. Die sind ahead
of schedule haben wir doch gelernt. Ahead of schedule. Nein. Achtung. Yolo. Okay, dass
der grappling hook manchmal verbugt, das nervt mich. Hier war doch noch einer eben. Oh, Ammo
Leer. Oh, Ammo Leute. Ich brauche Moon, haben sie in Gears of War immer gesagt. Gears of
War glaube ich eines der schlecht übersetzten Spiele aller Zeiten. Guck mal. Nein, die Kiste
ist einfach despawned. Captain Poggers, ich kann dich nicht holen. Ich habe das. Ich zeige
euch jetzt mal den besten Spot auf der ganzen Map. Aber der klappt nicht immer. Der klappt
nicht immer. Hier oben. Wenn die Wand kaputt ist, wenn. Ah nee, jetzt hat es nicht geklappt.
Wenn die Wand kaputt ist, niemand guckt da oben hin. Niemand. Wenn hier drinnen Action
ist, niemand. Guck mal. Ja, niemand. Niemand wird hier hoch gucken. Ich bleibe jetzt hier
einfach stehen und werfe motion Sensors. Und wenn einer reinkommt, wird da hipfired.
Und gleich machen sie die Wand kaputt und rechnet auch keine mit mir hier oben. Easy.
Schön in die Ecke campen. Beste Pose. Great hiding spots. Guck mal, da rennen sie da
vorum. Next. Motion Sensor. Ah yes. Die Drohne. Was? Oh nein, der hat die Tür zugemacht, bevor
ich killen konnte. Was soll das hier? High Octane Gameplay, Leute. High Octane Gameplay.
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass es absolut massive, skilligste Gameplay aller Zeiten ist. Ich
hab den High Ground. Ich hab den High Ground. Oh. Zack, Zack. Kommt rein, Leute. Kommt rein.
Oh, jetzt spawnen sie sogar noch hier oben. Ich brauch Amu. Mal gucken. Nee, hat nicht
funktioniert. Egal. Wir können ja einfach wieder hoch. Das klappt aber nicht immer.
Seht ihr, das ist trickreich. Da musst du schon richtig Elevenhead sein, dass das funktioniert.
Vielleicht von hier, vielleicht von hier. Ah, nice. Achtung, Achtung. Oh. Der sieht
mich nicht, der sieht mich nicht, Leute. Der sieht mich nicht. Ich bewege mich nicht, der
sieht mich nicht. What? What? Die sind despawned. Die sind despawned.
Five Head Position, Leute. Five Head Position. Ich sag's euch. Ich schau mal, ob ich rüber
kann. Five Head Position. Next Level Shit. Ich glaube, ich muss runter. Shit. Da gibt
es Spots, aber hier gerade nicht anscheinend. 666 ist ein Cheater, sagt er. Da hat uns noch
nicht mal meine Six Head Position jetzt was gebracht. 666 ist ein Cheater. Ja, tja.
Wir haben ja ein Scoreboard, wo wir nicht sehen, was die Gegner so treiben. Dementsprechend
werden wir das überhaupt nicht überprüfen können, ob das vielleicht ein Cheater ist
oder nicht. Game? Hallo? Warum ist es jetzt auf einmal off zone? Alles klar. Einfach ins
Ausbefördert. Einfach mitten hier gesetzt. Fettlich, retz dich. Einfach mitten die Linie
gesetzt hier, Mensch. Was ist das denn hier für krasses Map Design wieder? Six Head Design.
Das grenzt schon fast an Eleven Head Design hier. Oh, da ist ein Panzer gestuckt. What?
Das Two Tapper Girl hat mich Two Tapped, wie es aussieht. Ohne jetzt Erkennung zu haben
von wo. Two Tapper Girl. Nice. Das Gurl. Das, sorry, das Gurl. Das Two Tapper Gurl.
Ja. Ey, jawoll. Auf geht's. Volle Pulle. Nice. Ich weiß gar nicht, was hier besser
zu Defenden ist. Wahrscheinlich hängt es davon ab, wo die Gegner langpushen. Ich glaube nicht,
dass das hier wirklich so einen großen Unterschied macht. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Mensch, nimm
halt deine beschissene Waffe raus und kill den. Und mach nicht erst drei Stunden geile Akrobatik
mit der MP9 in den Händen, bis du anfangen kannst zu schießen. Guck, da ist es. Seht
nicht, das Two Tapper Gurl. Aero Child, Dankeschön für den Sub. Oh, ZZ Reds. Nein,
ein Res. Geht nicht. Res geht nicht, oder? Hinter euch Leute, hinter euch. Nein. Ich
spawn lieber bei euch rein. Das klappt so, glaube ich, nicht. Ich glaube, es geht los.
Das Two Tapper Gurl. Das musst du jetzt dran glauben. Ein wenig vereimt, aber trotzdem
ganz gut gemacht, würde ich sagen. Ich dachte, da liegt einer. Habt ihr auch gedacht, hier
liegt einfach einer? B kriegen wir nicht mehr, Leute. B kriegen wir nicht. B kriegen wir
nicht. Captain Peng, ich hole dich. Nein. Jawoll. Wow, das Two Tapper Gurl, das geht voll
ab. Guckt es euch an? Oh. Ich bräuchte Ammo. Haben wir hier irgendwo was? Ja, ich habe
ein Adler. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Wonka. Oh, oh. Fuck. Ich dachte, ich komme nur irgendwie rüber.
Nice. Two Tress. Und jetzt noch, was ist das hier? Jetzt können wir das mal ausprobieren.
Boah das lasert ja man, das ist ja pock und ich spiele mp9 die übelst rumzieht das ding
lasert ja richtig
Oh oh, oh oh, oh oh schlecht ich dachte das sind eigene leute
ne halo spielen wir heute nicht mehr wir sind das dawnbreaker squad wir müssen das jetzt
hier carryen
der morg das morgendämmerer squad erinnert sich noch einer an diese oh jetzt wird aber
b ganz schön ganz schön voll erinnert sich noch einer an die grandiose übersetzung aus
battlefield 4 der morgendämmerer oh da kommt gleich noch mehr ich kann da nicht rüber
ja alles klar aber die gehen gut durch hier das müssen wir jetzt wir müssen jetzt erstmal
den advanced was advanced nein wir müssen die gegner am advanced hindern jetzt hab
ich's mehr denglisch in einen satz packen
achso hier ist ja wieder die map zu ende ja ist ja gut jetzt game come on sterbt halt
mal oh da kommt fünf spieler an gegner gleich das tut aber gurl ist bestimmt auch dabei
nein tu tappt wieder guck hier da ist es hat's mich gebashed wieder
massif res okay da ist das geschwitze wieder kommt sich
hervor wie in warzone schau in warts nee warts war das andere von wo wo wer hat mich denn
bitteschön jetzt gekillt rush borken ja also chat ganz ehrlich wenn also in ermangelung
alternativen ist rush noch der modus der mir aktuell am meisten zusagt ja das stimmt
weg es ist einfach nicht so krasser clusterfuck wie die anderen und das ist schon mal riesiger
vorteil das hat er sich so gedacht das hat er sich so gedacht du hast nirgends deckung
ja das ist das tolle map design von bf 22 42 guck mal da kommt was
gibt mir ammo achtung big brain move massif brain nein oh das ist zu viel es ist einfach
zu viel ich muss auch esl jumpschotten um die ecke wieder anfangen es ist einfach zu
viel gerade ja man kann man kann in bot games richtig gut waffe leveln ja das war schon
seit release so deswegen verstehe ich ja auch nicht warum sie in portal die xp deaktiviert
haben muss ich das mal überlegen in portal spielst du ging in echte spieler und kannst
theoretisch boosten aber du kannst auch single play gegen bots boosten also warum solltest
du da nicht in portal gegen echte spieler spielen können also wisst ihr wie ich mein
wenn du eh boosten kannst warum da nicht wenigstens noch gegen echte spieler erlauben versteht
ihr wie ich meine es ist eigentlich total bescheuert nein du siehst mich nicht lmg legit
lcmg nein lege henne dachte wir haben es jetzt an dem objective
ja die bots ja die bots sind für für waffen gut ja es reicht ja schon ja hallo sterben
please aber für attachments reicht ja schon oh hier kommen hier kommen gleich 50 billionen
tegner runter leute seht ihr das meine güte kommt euch das vor wie 16 verses 16 ist das
eine falsche anzeige das kommt einem so viel vor du trass du trass ok wenn wir klug haben
ich kann mich nicht runter kriechen ah yes excellent versteckstor poggers versteckt leute
mich sieht keiner mich kann einfach keiner sehen unmöglich unmöglich mich zu sehen was
du kannst mich nicht sehen was soll das hier und ich habe ihn ja überhaupt nicht erkannt
da sieht er mich einfach muss wallhack sein genau ne das ist in den motion sensor halt
gewesen weil das game ist ja eh permanent auf der auf der minimap hat also supressor
bringt gar nix supressor ist wirklich total overrated gebatet outdated in dem spiel vielleicht
habe ich ich weiß gar nicht wie das wieder eingang da vorne aussieht wenn ich ehrlich
bin ich kämpfe mich jetzt hier hinter die kiste
überhaupt nicht so was kannst du halt 16 verses 16 machen aber im leben nicht 32 32 was
die haben schon lege hände gemacht ich fasse es nicht die sind schon am start alter wie
schnell waren die dann bitteschön hier am start ich mache da noch irgendwie aber wir
haben die fußt ok ich mache da noch sonst wie action vorne und die sind schon wieder
am start wurde maus input verbessert auf jawoll jawoll die fußt die fußt die fußt die fußt
die fußt die fußt die fußt die fußt die fußt entschärfungs hände am start das
war close das war close af leute close af sei euch das kann man sogar mal klippen das
war echt klar das war wirklich knapp ja durchbruch kannst du nicht spielen mit 128 das ist nicht
möglich
back da kann ich jetzt nicht mit rechnen wir müssen eigentlich nur uns alle fest decken
auf ein m komm und dann easy win was chat würdest du sagen dass sie sich mit der schadens
begrenzung mühe gegeben haben ach du meinst dass sie das game noch irgendwie versuchen
zu retten nicht wirklich sie haben halt ein paar m-coms gesetzt war es mehr oder weniger
ich die fuße ich die fuße ich die fuße spieler kasse die fußt gott und auch hier
was ist hier hinten wo ist der dude wo wo ist er muss hier unten drunter irgendwo sein
die sollen sich auf die wichtigen sachen generell konzentrieren das problem ist dass
die ja schon komplett in verzug sind mit dem game weil es in so einem scheiß zustand raus
gekommen ist ansonsten hätte man sagen können ja ihr müsst halt einfach nur content bringen
aber nein just just content so einfach ist es nicht wir müssen das spiel fixen und content
bringen und das für alle erdenklichen bereiche aus diesem game das ist tatsächlich echt
keine leichte herausforderung ja okay ich habe keine ahnung von wo ich schieß jetzt
einfach mal in die richtung deswegen leute ist 16 versus 16 oder sagen wir mal so bis
zu 32 zu 32 einfach gut du kannst gegner richtig cool outplay und ich gucke dann nicht zehn
von der seite an wo du nicht hingeguckt hast ich glaube hier an erkennt man es jetzt eigentlich
ganz gut wenn du hiermit wenn du hier mit hirn spielst kannst du wirklich was reißen
weil du 23 gegner killst und dann ist gut was bei 128 einfach nicht geht easy win was
sollten was sind die besten games aller zeiten die man gespielt haben sollte oder muss ich
mir müsste ich mir mal gedanken drüber machen auf jeden fall du sollst auf jeden fall black
messer spielen das half life 1 remake weil das mittlerweile komplett fertig ist mittlerweile
sogar in der special mega edition oder so wobei ich sagen würde dass nicht alles gelungen
ist in den letzten paar levels aber insgesamt ist es die mit abstand beste half life experience
die man so spielen kann und das sollte wirklich jeder mal gespielt haben wenn ihr mich fragt
besser als half life 2 kriegt man jetzt ex bei portal weiß ich nicht zumindest bei der
offiziellen playlist bekommt man ex wie man hier sieht
mal hier der chat richtig also hier der in-game chat die leute freuen sich also zumindest
da kriegst du ex beste spiele aller zeiten müsste man gedanken zu machen also du sollst
auf jeden fall black messer spielen wenn du auf storygames spielst wenn du auf storygames
stehst und was jetzt eigentlich kein game ist solltest du auf jeden fall to the moon
spielen erinnert sich noch jemand dran wie wir to the moon gespielt haben im stream richtig
bible thump cry ge ich habe übrigens jetzt in den neuen teil gespielt im poster factory
hat nichts mit sus zu tun ist auch ganz ok also der hat ja nach to the moon noch zwei
neue spiele gemacht er hat finding paradise gemacht und im poster factory und ist ist
ist auch in ordnung aber tun sie immer noch mein favorit oder dabei da sind auch wieder
einige schüsse durchgeflogen habt es gesehen wo wo ach da man was ist hier oben auf dem
kran los du gehst auf den kran hoch siehst ein gegner stehen fünf da darf ich vergessen
fünf das ist fast die helfe vom gegner team monkeys kranparty beste spiele aller zeiten
ist sehr subjektiv und vor allem hat glaube ich jeder schon mal gemacht ich auch aber
da war zwar nicht so durchdacht heute würde ich wahrscheinlich andere nehmen kann man
sich eigentlich sehr viel am nice man kann sich sehr viel ist der da drin der ist da
betroffen achtung alter ich hasse es wenn der grappling hook nicht funktioniert
hallo game please hinten btf das ist einfach durchgeflogen alter du kannst die hier ganz
schön outmove oder deswegen mag ich es wenn sie ein bisschen weniger sind was ist hier
los alles schon da das ist einfach eine ganze ecke durch hau barer ok wenn ich 5 5 wie wie
die fußke die fußke achtung der ist da drin das macht so bock in dem fall sogar wenn
die gegner outmove und ein bisschen big brain play sich auszahlt richtig nice ok jetzt
blickst du mal durch die fußke jetzt bin ich bin ich nicht aber wir haben die fuß
nice so pock das ist das ist tatsächlich wie ein bisschen vertikales noch scha tdm
hier ein bisschen wo da oben jetzt von hinten alter jetzt blick ich den mal durch die grane
die die ist es ist es gerade es ist gräne oder gräne heißt das die gräne oben drüber
machen es natürlich ein bisschen komplexer da muss man sagen da pickt man nicht so nicht
so einfach durch wo was ist aber vielleicht können wir uns auch so ein kran hochstelzen
oder in der s krieg ich geschultet ok packt ab in die s over hier da oben ist er seht
ihn ok das war ok ok ok wie wie ich an jeder ecke gerade aber das ist mir nicht
das ist noch halbwegs überschaubar also dass mit 16 vs 16 geht das wirklich klar da kann
ich mich nicht beschweren aber vielleicht schaffen wir es jetzt an der ersten base zu
defenden wir haben ja nur noch b und aktuell konzentrieren die sich witzigerweise eigentlich
auf die komplett falsche seite null hallo ich will aussteigen ich will aussteigen ich
will aussteigen aussteigen aussteigen hallo spiel aus will aussteigen ich darf nicht aussteigen
es ist kaputt was war es jetzt los ach jetzt geht's
ich wollte es eigentlich schon ausmachen aber ich kann ich muss mich auf spiel konzentrieren
ich kriege anfälle oder nein noch zwei tickets nein die haben es doch
gehabt die wurden gerade um den sieg gebetet die gegner hatten die es nicht ach das andere
hatten wir noch nee das andere war doch weg oder ach wir hatten das andere noch dann habe
ich nicht gecheckt ich dachte ich dachte das andere mkomm ist schon ist schon weg deswegen
habe ich auch vorhin gesagt die haben müssen nur noch b holen wurde nicht auf der map angezeigt
ach so dann ist ja klar kann man ja auch nicht erwarten dass das funktioniert wo kämen wir
denn dahin
fps kann sich das durchaus lohnen aber je nachdem was du jetzt hast
der andere seite wenn es nicht akut ist kannst du auch warten bis es irgendwann mal in fünf
jahren wieder billiger wird doch da 7704 kerne da 8706 jetzt können wir die fendt action am
stellen ist jetzt da oben hin nein ok dann wollte ich nicht hin aber wir können wir können auch da hochfahren mit auch ok und jetzt hier gehen wir an die an die gannen und stellten alles was hier ankommt
da hat er nicht mit gerechnet der gute das ist unfair das ist wirklich unfair die ecke hier oben
guck mal wir haben als defender viel akut ist zwar doof wir haben als defender viel bessere posi das ist
unfair bei uns abgehört mir poc pockelfield 2042 poggers poggers viel so um auf explodiert er einfach alles was boris geschütz
ist das nicht der sinn einer verteidigungstellung doch aber das hat ja mit der realität nichts zu tun das soll ja gut spielbar sein
ich finde das nicht so gut durchdacht weil hier rechts hast du überhaupt keine deckung das heißt die gegner werden meistens recht
pushen also quasi andere andere seite kein poggers ist weg mal mal kürze motion sensor hier hoch
oder oben kommen jetzt viele monka es ok da kommen jetzt einige kippen poggers bis denn macht gut also ich bin
auch eine stunde ich bin auch eine stunde und falls noch einer mitspielen will vielleicht habe ich
euch sogar schon auf origin da wer weiß vieler squad geht eigentlich immer besser als dreier squad
oder am besten solo ich habe mich eh wieder ich habe mich ohne scheiß frag mich wie der loss das
aushält dass die ganze zeit solo zu spielen aber man jede was ihm gefällt ja ich verstehe es bloß nicht
das hat geklatscht das hat auch geklatscht das hat auch geklatscht nein ich wollte sich klettern dass
der geklettert hat hat mich gerade das leben gekostet ich wollte eigentlich springen um die
eck aber da hat gemeint ich kletter jetzt ich kletter jetzt den block hoch ja in game links
rechts du musst glaube ich dann cash lernen geht es wieder das ist ein bug den es mit update 3
jetzt neu gibt ein neues bug bug feature quasi mit ein feature bug sozusagen also wenn es so
was gibt wie ein feature bug dann auf jeden fall oder gehen auf b man dann den bellfin zwar oder
kommt der pence man kommt an jetzt habe ich ein problem wenn der pence man hier angefahren kommt
aber der pence man fährt zum glück nicht ran das ist gut dass der nicht ranfährt
ok ich brauche alles einsammeln hier 50 schuss
so jetzt haben wir die seite easy defended gehen wir mal rüber der berg hier um den
könne ich halt echt kaum einnehmen das ist ziemlich ziemliche pepega geschichte
ok der hit hat gar nichts der dude alda keck wie oder sind geschütz boris
game journalist modus ja so hat es hier so hat er echt gehittet ich bin übrigens jemand der
früher übelst gelästert hat so nach dem motto alda guckt euch mal an wie scheiße irgendwie
spiel tester spielen und wie können die games überhaupt bewerten und das bin ich heute deutlich
entspannter muss ich sagen ich meine ich finde es da trotzdem komisch warum man gerade die
leute shooter bewerten lässt die shooter nicht spielen ok aber du hast als spieler journalist
sicherlich besseres zu tun als ein game quasi auf höheres level zu kreiten am besten schon
am besten schon theory crafting in der beta machen und so was beste waffen sind sonst was also ich
glaube da muss man ein bisschen verständnis für haben dass sie eben auch rein job bedingt
nicht die krassesten ohne sein können wobei es ja schon ganz gut wäre wenn man die leute die ganz
gut sind in multiplayer fps zum beispiel dann auch die multiplayer fps spielen das aber
besser kriegst auf twitch bock wupp arrived so bando dankeschön für den sub die sollten so
eine art grundkonzept von hier selbstverständlich wer also so diese ganzen leute ist dann schlecht
bewerten weil was weiß ich was ist denn so typische too much water denn was ist so typische so eine
typische sache wo ich manchmal denk pains camp alda wie kommen die auf so eine idee
jetzt gerade nichts ein
ich bekomme experience hier nur über diese offiziellen ja genau kapett ist zu schwer und
so dinge ja das genau sowas in der richtung ich bekomme xp aber nur in der offiziellen
rush playlist leute morgen ist freitag kann das sein wisst ihr dass ich am wochenende
nicht mal eine steuer erklärung fertig machen muss also nicht die steuer erklärung die sachen
ich im steuerberater schicke ich drück mich da immer das ganze jahr davor lul die fenster
auf diskade das ging die letzte male echt in die hohes ich glaube ich mache morgen
ein video zu rush so wenn ich mir das kratzer überleg was immer denn hier gelandet beste
posi ich glaube hier wollte ich schon immer mal hin ich spreche einfach mal rein
glaube ich mache morgen was zu rush leute jemanden gute richtig leisten click titel im
kopf und und und nicht nicht die standardding so rettet rush battlefield 2042 ich meine ob
das spiel jetzt gerettet wird habe ich jetzt glaube schon 50 verschiedenen titeln verarbeitet
in irgendeiner art und weise jemand eine gute idee für einen titel für ein rush video
ich habe keine ahnung was mich hier gerade oder pence man der pence man rush ist back
battlefield 2042 rushed in den abgrund das ist eine ziemlich gute idee aber man muss
immer mit dem lowdurchschnitt IQ auf youtube rechnen das checken die leute nicht dass das
ein video über rush ist diese lange ersehnte funktion ist endlich zurück das ist das ist
das ist wirklich clickbait 2.0 aber ich glaube in dem fall zieht es mehr dass man sagt rush
weil die leute eben rush kennen rush großschreiben ja das e das selbstverständlich schreibe
ich rush groß mein jeder ein bisschen clickbait kram kann ja mittlerweile auch also falls
jemand oder kommt was big brain idee hat nach alter wie die haben geplantet die könne ich
planten einfach so banana planter kennt das noch jemand kennt noch jemand diese montage
die der fabian hochgeladen hat oh das habe ich gut gemacht oder das habe ich wirklich
pock gemacht da müsste mich mal loben dass ich quasi e gedrückt halte ohne moving den
typ noch gesehen habe easy das auto da kann das sein dass ich heute wirklich ganz gut
drauf bin also sowohl ein technisch geht heute er geht heute echt klar als auch movement
und play technisch wirklich in ordnung also für 37 jährigen boomer geht das doch auch
geht das doch
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass mir was war das denn was hat mir denn hier ins gesicht
gepustet ja das macht auch mehr spaß das stimmt schon
oh schneiber leute xx hd jetzt kommts pass auf xx hd oh fuck ich glaube man macht das
mit der sniper nicht mit der pistole oder dank rush nicht mehr lost ist auch nicht schlecht
die idee ist mit das finde ich gut ist mit rush der durchbruch gelungen das muss ich
mir aufschreiben das finde ich gut gelingt nicht gelingt mit gelingt moment gelingt mit
rush der durchbruch das ist so richtig jebait titel so nach dem motto rush breakthrough was
auch immer der finde ich gut ok jetzt xx hd time leute ok fertig xx hd vielleicht liegt
es auch ein halo dass ich heute bessere besser eme oder auch nicht xx hd schneiber ist nichts
für mich leute xx hd schneiber ne ne da geht nix kann ich nicht bin ich nicht advanced
für genug wo sind denn überhaupt gegner ok endlich mal wieder eine ordentliche waffe
und spiel xx hd hat nicht funktioniert hast du eigentlich mehr oder weniger feste stream
zeiten habe ich feste stream zeiten chat ich glaube mehr random als ich kann man nicht
streamen sonntag sonntag so 9 30 10 uhr bis 13 14 uhr das ist eigentlich die einzig
feste streamzeit die ich habe achtung achtung wir machen jetzt big plan fack die moni war
leer die moni war leer no aber auch weil vorher wieder die schüsse nicht geregt haben win
easy max rushed battlefield von seinem art drive nicht schlecht maus m coms disarmt leute
ist das eigentlich der diverse specialist oder der hacker man das habe ich jetzt immer
noch nicht gecheckt ich habe jetzt verschiedene sachen gehört ist das wingsuit grill diverse
oder ist der hacker mein diverse nicht dass es sandans ok dass ich habe nämlich wieder
widersprüchliche sachen gehört die meditante nee der sandans ist das wingsuit grill ok
oh renewal mal gucken ob es jetzt besser flutscht wann kommen elite skins für die specialist
es gab heute ein boris weihnachtsmann skin da wurde wieder entfernt wie es aussieht
zumindest habe ich den in game nicht geile citrone du musst deinen cash lernen nee dein
ja frag mich nicht ich habe im vorfeld nur gelesen muss irgendwie sein game cash klären
weiß ich ob das eine all jing geschichte ist oder ob man seinen profil ordner löschen
muss und danach die settings neu machen keine ahnung das ist irgendwas was später noch
kommt keine ahnung ist das hier so einen jetzt ist weg das hätte auch so einen so einen
labyrinth sein können wo man so gucken muss wie man da so durchkommt so auf gehts hovercraft
jawohl bärme kein hovercraft leute hier dieses ding dieser dieser granatwerfer da ist so
dermaßen schlecht wo man sich einfach nur fragen kann wer ist auf die geile idee gekommen
diesen granatwerfer einzubauen ok ich lebe mal oh nee ich mach doch nicht die idee gehandelt
warum gibt es manchmal und warum gibt es manchmal einsteige animation und manchmal nicht wir
werden es nie erfahren ich wollte gerade sagen wenn er jetzt nicht stirbt dann rast ich aber
aus damit hast du nicht gerechnet oder heute geht aber gut rein heute geht aber echt gut
rein muss man immer lassen hier achtung achtung big brain play o man ich hasse es wenn das
game eine big brain plays nicht mitmacht massive das war klippwürdig oder dieses kommt diese
komplette aktion war doch echt klippwürdig leute das muss man das muss man klippen und
er ist nun fertig er ist fertig es geht immer noch weiter und jetzt und jetzt noch ein und
jetzt noch massive sniper kill hinten drauf passt auf jetzt noch 360 ok jetzt hätte er
funktionieren können ich bleib ich bleib lieber bei meiner ordentlichen waffe was haben wir
hier zu bieten was haben wir da taugt es hallo ich will aufheben spiel ah wer spielt dann
sowas wo ist meine waffe für meine waffe wieder meine waffe ist blocken meine waffe
ist verpackt ich kann moment ach da liegt die angeblich ok alles klar das akok visier
war das ja panzer nehme ich mit so war das nicht gedacht bettel fiel vor den kopf geschaut
ein paar mauschen sensors schmeißen irgendwo da drüben ist was lege hinne hinter mir kommt
was aber vielleicht kann ich oder wenn wir abgeähmt hier da werden wir abgeähmt game
nicht rumbacken ok irgendwann irgendwann irgendwann muss er ja mal 14 leute 14 14 weg
bämbel bämbel hast du schon auerclass gespielt ja und ich habe voll versagt bei auerclass
ach ich stecke in der wand ich kann nicht wiederbelebt werden ok da machst du nix
schmeißen mauschen sensors zu wissen was abgeht auerclass ist richtig wird wird wird
wird wird wir sind hinterm schild da kann nichts passieren ja da hat mich geteebäckt
ich habe es gesehen aber der wollte mir damit ja eigentlich nur sagen das ist ok dass er
mich nicht schätzt pass auf big brain play alter jetzt kriegen sie aber auf den sack
das ist die big das ist die größte feife runde die ich bisher hatte in dem spiel richtig
feifett kannst du dich mal heilen
oh oh da kommt eine granate achter ja ich bin zu viel am husten ihr habt recht ihr habt
recht chat aber ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll zum arzt gehen wird garantiert nix bringen
weil die eigentlich nie was machen sondern so standard dinger von sich geben außerdem
was sollen sie machen gegen zu viel husten oh es geht noch nicht los
charlie mike nicht mehr oscar mike charlie mike ok das war zu viel das war zu viel
aber gameplay 100 ja endlich hier jetzt geht mal was das liegt aber auch am squad ganz
ehrlich das liegt auch mit am squad wenn du wenn du ordentliche squad mates hast dann
geht es einfach war mir fett den fatal dabei und den captain poggers und in serious marks
da kann ich schief gehen so war das jetzt eigentlich nicht gedacht
habt ihr die habt ihr die hells anzeige gesehen über den köpfen der leute
schuten die tangos gar keine frage ich bin so ein krasser tango shooter
fack tango hat mich geschudet von der seite tango shooter aber zumindest wisst ihr was
das alles gute an dem stream von heute ist ich habe zumindest für das video
morgen einfach gameplay ich nehme einfach den stream und schneide das zusammen
fertig ich glaube die checken gar nicht dass ich von hier oben anstürzen kann
oder ob das ding gar nicht so klar
also ich denke mal so eins zwei runden bis 22 uhr gehen noch aber dann ist
schluss für heute ich sag es nur schon mal morgen wird das 20 42 bashing video
veröffentlicht was hoffentlich runter genommen ist doch ein nice spiel das
video werde ich nicht löschen warum soll ich das video jemals löschen es war
halt und ich meine es ist im kern immer noch unfertig und undurchdacht nur weil
sie mit rush und 16 vs 16 quasi ihre eigenen design entscheidungen zum teil
wieder zurück genommen haben ist es jetzt besser spielbar
oh halbe stunde noch wisst ihr was dann ist um 22 uhr die stammzuschauer werden
wissen auf our class irgendjemand hatte kann auch our class gefragt
22 ist schon spät
boomer müde bettke
achte auf die dead zone jetzt und die spawnpunkte ja das ist pepega our
class richtig pepega oder schon bebäger sozusagen wir sind mal attacker ich
glaube attack habe ich auf our class legit noch nie
die nächste section ist auch doof wo du einfach nur über die wüste laufen
musst nächste nächste base muss man einfach komplett komplett über die
düne laufen ohne deckung ohne alles
richtig bebäger da unten sind sie drin guckt euch mal vielleicht habe ich
glück und kann mich hier rüber kreppeln irgendwie
ok dass dass dass die sein hier drinne ist ja wirklich der hammer das alter du
checkst ja mal gar nicht wohl wo hier irgendwas ist
super da ist out da muss man erst mal drauf kommen dass die restliche hälfte
vom haus einfach warum ist die restliche warum ist die restliche dings vom haus
einfach aus zonen was bescheuert wir hatten so viel wer ist auf die beknackte
idee gekommen da rechnest du doch nicht mit dass die hälfte vom haus auf einmal
out of map ist das meinest du ja ist wirklich ist richtig hängen geblieben
ihr seht mich nicht ihr könnt mich gar nicht sehen was was habt ihr habt ihr
gesehen wie es wieder durchgeflogen ist ich habe schon aufgehört zu schießen
weil ich mir dachte der fällt jetzt um das ist einfach wieder straight durch
gegangen zwanzig kugeln oder könnt ihr nicht sagen dass es irgendwie an ppega
eben lag das war genau drauf so easy wir haben es oder haben wir es
doch wir haben sie jawoll dass mich nehme ich mit
so die nächste base ist wirklich hart hängen geblieben
wir müssen jetzt komplett hier über die über die dünnen drüber passt mal auf ja
fahr schon durch fahr schon durch fahr weiter fahr weiter
rush expert nein doch kein rush expert so macht man das nämlich eigentlich man
fährt schon in durch die durch die oft so und durch bis es dann aufgeht
geben geben fahrdurch
geben rush exports unter sich hier sie schon sie ja so leicht kommen wir nie
wieder durch so leicht kommen wir nie wieder durch das ist wirklich schwierig
hier durchzukommen noch mal monarch ist ich steige aus max ich steige aus macht es ganz
die autohocken bleiben
next next next next
wasserblatt aus geschudet aber vielleicht kriegen wir b da geht an b ran
das schaut alles so leer aus und keine details ja das ist ja auch eines meiner
kritikpunkte am map design hier das shanghai 2014 war das glaube ich
battlefield rausgekommen ist das shanghai 2014 einfach mal besser detailreicher
und und lebendiger und schöner vor allem ausgesehen hat als es jetzt so
sowas wie kaleidoskop zum beispiel tut was halt schon irgendwo ein leichtes
armutszeugnis ist wenn da wenn da quasi acht jahre oder so dazwischen liegen
warum hat er tut sich gerade nicht geheilt ich habe ich habe mir doch ich
habe noch den booster reingedrückt oder war das schon 2013 ich weiß gar nicht
wenn es raus ja aber die 128 spieler ich weiß dass es kappa und schibet ist im
chat aber die 128 spieler sind ja dafür keine ausrede irgendwie wenn es halt
nicht funktioniert mit 128 dann lässt es halt weg und außerdem wüsste ich nicht
warum das ein problem sein sollte du konntest battlefield 3 sogar ohne
probleme spielen mit 128 spieler
alter die werden geklatscht aber gerade
ja ach das ist das schild gut
easy clap ja easy ist clap ich kann die map hier überhaupt nicht weiß kann ich
was ist außer außer sand sand findet man ja relativ schnell
da drüben ist b ok die krabbel die krabbeln hocken uns jetzt einfach da
rüber hinter mir ist was und vor mir ist was ist natürlich doof
achtung ich muss mal motion sensor rüber schmarrt perfekt perfekt ist er mit dem
maus nein unter mir
heck gräschtsche kecks
Was machen die Dudes da hinten denn bitteschön gerade?
Irgendwie krasse Party hier am Schild.
Oh, das ist ein langes Comment Chat, ich lese es gleich, ich stelle mich in die Ecke und
lese kurz.
Joman schreibt, vor 10 Jahren dachte ich heute hätte man die allerbesten Games, da
man ja gute Features beibehalten und Fehler ausmerzen kann, aber irgendwie haben sie
in jedem Game immer wieder alles erneut über einen Haufen geworfen, was manchmal gut war,
manchmal schlecht.
Leute, ich sage euch genau so, wenn es dir vor 10 Jahren so ging, mir ging es vor 20
Jahren so, vor 20 Jahren, ungelogen, ich habe es schon öfters gesagt im Stream, ich dachte
mir so zu Zeiten, wo keine Ahnung, wo Half Life 1 rausgekommen ist und sowas, sagst du
mir, meine Güte, stell dir mal vor, 2010 oder so, 2020, wie krass das alles sein muss,
das ist dann quasi komplett das geilste vom geilsten zusammen und wir haben nur geile
Games, habe ich damals gedacht.
Meine Stimme hört sich anders an, ja, wahrscheinlich bin ich ein bisschen heißer, weil ich so viel
husten muss, keine Ahnung.
Das dachte ich damals, habe ich ja schon öfters erzählt und es ist halt nicht so, die Games
sind tendenziell sogar eher schlechter, ha, lull, was war das für ein Kill, was war das
für ein Kill, oh, ich habe keine, Tango, wir shooten die Tangos, Leute, ich bin der
beste Tango Shooter, ich shoote die Tangos, kann man da oben drauf, irgendwie so, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, hat er einen Wallhack, was ist mit ihm los, woher weiß er, dass ich das stelle,
bing, bing, bing
Wo ist hier was?
Wo sind sie? Aha!
Please game! Was war das wieder?
Rush gibt es nur über Portal. Gibt es das überhaupt? Ja!
Alles voll! Das Schöne ist ja, dass du keine Custom-Server brauchst, sondern es gibt eine offizielle...
Ach, das war's! Das war die letzte Base! Nice! Easy win!
Ähm... Die Rush-Playlist ist ja quasi die offizielle von DICE.
Richtig Legehennen waren wir, ja.
Richtig, richtig. Das Top-Legehennen-Squad.
In biologischer Haltung.
Assign-Arm-Kills! Natürlich!
Also meine Pistolen-Kills waren eindeutig am wichtigsten in der Runde.
Also das hat wirklich die ganze Runde gecarried, da ich zwei Pistolen-Kills gemacht habe.
Also was die sich gedacht haben, mit der Anzeige von diesen Dingern am Ende, erschließt sich mir null.
Rush fühlt sich so gut an, sagt der Chet. Ganz ehrlich, meine Meinung ist, Rush fühlt sich brauchbar an.
Und es kommt einem jetzt vor wie die Erfindung des Rads, weil der Rest einfach so unterirdisch kacke ist.
Aber ich muss sagen, Chet, ihr seid schon richtig, richtig next-level Fivehead wieder.
Denn den Titel finde ich gut.
Also Titel morgen von dem Video wird wahrscheinlich wirklich sein, gelingt mit Rush der Durchbruch.
Sind diese Sprüche cringe? Ja, aber richtig.
Richtig gringe.
Was sind wir? Attacker? Ach, Attacker hatten wir hier noch nicht.
Oh nee, ich kann mich an die Defender Runde erinnern. Einfach Leute, offenes Feld, offenes Feld ohne irgendwas.
Ich habe ja eigentlich gesagt, mit Battlefield 2042 Videos ist jetzt ja mal gut.
Aber es gibt jetzt halt Sachen, wo ich gerne drüber reden will.
Und immerhin, die Battlefield 2042 Videos haben auch immer gute Aufrufe.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich will jetzt nicht die Leute, die mich so das letzte Jahr über abonniert haben,
auch für die ein oder anderen IT-Technik-Themen gar so lange warten lassen, bis da mal wieder was kommt.
Ich mache das ja zweigleisig und das war übrigens, Leute, das war die beste Entscheidung überhaupt,
so zweigleisig das Ganze zu machen, dass ich quasi IT-Themen und Gaming-Shooter-Themen mache.
Weil Gaming-Shooter-Themen gibt es nicht so viele, die mich interessieren meistens.
Und IT-Stells gibt es nicht so viele, die das machen.
Und die da auch quasi halbwegs gehaltvoll was zu sagen können.
Das war doch nie im Leben ein Headshot-Game.
Okay, hier haben sie wenigstens darauf geachtet, dass man hier nicht headklitschen kann.
Okay, das war Pepega-Aimed gerade.
Ach, Legehände ist schon raus, guckt es euch mal an.
Die Legehände ist schon raus hier.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ja, da können wir schon mal rüberpushen.
Hat sich der Recoil geändert?
Das habe ich nicht gelesen.
So weit runtergescrollt habe ich in den Patchnotes nicht, dass ich mir die Details angeguckt hätte.
Also die MP9 spielt sich immer noch, immer noch nice.
Oh, fuck. Oh, shit.
Okay, Legehände, Legehände, Legehände mache ich jetzt gerade.
Legehände.
Da waren gerade fünf Gegner.
Einfach mal reinsprayen.
Ich könnte, ich könnte ein bisschen Ammo geben.
Nein, die Ammo-Box, warum ist die Ammo-Box weg?
Die Legehände geht richtig ab gerade.
Guckt mal hier, wir gehen ja da durch wie nichts.
Poggers.
Poggers Pogchamp.
Hast du heute Spaß an Battlefield Chat?
Ich frage euch.
Was meint ihr, habe ich heute Spaß an Battlefield? Es gibt zur Auswahl.
Ja, nein und so ein bisschen.
Das ist übertrieben geil, ist das nicht, Chat?
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen.
Es ist nicht mehr ganz so, es ist nicht mehr ganz so Pains-Champ wie die ganze Zeit davor.
Und dabei, dabei.
Ich habe tatsächlich Spaß dran, weil es ist jetzt tatsächlich zum ersten Mal halbwegs spielbar.
Also aber auch nur dank Rush.
Der Rest hat sich ja nichts wirklich großartig getan.
Oh, oh der Pants-Man ist da. Nein, nein, nein.
Hol dich.
Next.
Ich kann wieder nicht springen, Leute.
Mein Sprung, meine Leertaste ist wieder einfach kaputt.
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Was ist das für eine Back-Scheiße immer?
Ich kann nicht springen.
Vielleicht kann ich das endklitschen, wenn ich hier drüber... Nee.
Okay.
Meine Leertaste ist kaputt.
Kann ich eigentlich nur noch sterben und hoffen, dass ich...
Warum geht die Leertaste einfach in einem Game zwischendurch nicht?
Der Rest funktioniert ja.
Ach, jetzt geht die Leertaste...
Hä?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was abgeht mit dem Spiel wieder.
Kamen unplatzierbare Bomben-Spots vor.
Ja, also die Maps haben schon ganz schöne Defender und Attacker-Bias, sagt man ja da so schön zu.
Aber insgesamt ist halt einfach dadurch, dass es 16 versus 16 ist, schon mal um Längen angenehmer.
Weil du hast halt nicht dieses übliche Problem...
Die Maps sacken immer noch, aber du hast halt nicht dieses übliche Problem,
wenn du einen Gegner siehst, dass sich zehn Gegner sehen.
Wenn du hier in Rush gute Plays machst, zum Beispiel sowas hier jetzt...
Das war ja eindeutig das beste Play aller Zeiten.
Dann killen dich die Leute dabei auch nicht.
Oh, die sind auf dem Dach.
Ich hoffe, das M-Com ist nicht auf dem Dach.
Wenn das M-Com auf dem Dach ist, dann raste ich aus.
Dann mache ich Instant-Uninstall wieder.
Also sollte das M-Com wirklich auf dem Dach sein, dann drehe ich durch.
Dieses Gebäude ist so brutal leer, ja.
Lege Henne!
Das M-Com ist schon mal nicht auf dem Dach.
Wo ist das andere?
Alter, die lassen sich aber auch schon ordentlich wegsprayen.
Wahrscheinlich wird als nächstes die MP9 genervt oder so.
Die nerven ja alles, was gut ist.
Autsch.
Ja, das Gebäude ist leer.
Es hat nichts an den Wänden hängen.
Es hat keine Einrichtung.
Oh doch, guck mal.
Es hat zwei Stühle.
Wir fahren mal aufs Dach.
Nicht, dass es was bringen würde, aber...
Können wir mal gucken, ob das irgendwie in das Gameplay integriert ist hier.
Äh, nee.
Das geht nicht.
Ähm, mit den Stockwerken.
Weil das Game hat ja nur Erdgeschoss und Dach.
In der Zwischen...
Innen drinnen ist ja nichts.
Nein, die M-Coms sind auf dem Dach.
Die M-Coms sind auf dem Dach.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Die fucking M-Coms sind auf dem Dach.
Nee.
Hä?
Sack.
Die M-Coms sind auf dem Dach.
Dice.
Was soll der Scheiß, man?
Ich dachte übrigens, dass da ist das M-Com.
Deswegen bin ich wieder runtergehüpft.
Ah, Gott.
Warum?
Habt ihr aus Breakthrough nichts gelernt, oder was?
Ihr Kacknoobs.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Wie kann man nur so bescheuert sein?
Sie können es einfach.
Sie haben es einfach drauf, ja.
Okay, wo war denn jetzt der Fahrstuhl hier noch mal?
Leute, ich bin verwirrt.
Wo war denn jetzt der Fahrstuhl?
Hier oben?
Da.
Dann spart man nicht mal auf dem Dach.
Ja, das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Okay, gegen eine DMR mit der MP9.
Just get the objective forehead.
Die Maps haben nicht genug Platz um die M-Coms.
Oh, nice.
Nice reintroppen.
Drop Stealths.
Oh, da ist Boris geschützt.
Boris.
Okay, ich meine, sie legen Hände, Leute.
Fuck.
Genau, bestes Argument immer.
Wenn es dir nicht gefällt, dann kauf es doch nicht.
Genau, immer, geht immer.
Okay, jetzt klastern die sich alle oben.
Das ist natürlich Müll.
Der Typ fährt runter?
Warum fährt er runter?
Das einzige M-Com ist da oben.
At portal full progression.
Nope, no pass.
Oh, wo sind wir denn hier?
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Alles klar.
Auch wieder ein paar Schüsse durchgegangen.
Aber immerhin sind wir schon mal auf dem Dach.
Das ist ja meistens schon mal ganz gut.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist unser Respawn jetzt down.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nein, ich wollte euch retzen.
Oh.
Ach, der ist über mir.
Oh, passt mal auf.
Ist der hier?
Sch gonft!
Sechshed Move.
Oh.
Aber vom Ansatz her war das gut, oder?
Vom Ansatz her kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ist natürlich der Heli gleich oben.
Oh, nein wir haben kein Ding mehr.
Shit.
Okay.
Wir müssen etwa richtig 3 Stunden laufen.
Die Innenräume sind ultralaut, die Maps sind halt nicht fertig.
Auf Jungs, kommt rein.
Gatschi-Bass.
Ah, der fährt schon da.
Die Musik.
Und rüber hier, rüber.
Rüber.
Die haben einen fucking Heli auch noch, die Defender.
Wer ist denn auf die kloreiche Idee gekommen, die M-Coms aufs Dach zu packen und den Defender
noch einen Heli zu geben?
Warum haben die einen Heli?
DICE!
Was habt ihr euch denn dabei gedacht?
Wer hat sich gedacht, ah ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist auf dem Dach.
Ja, Moment, das ist auf dem Dach.
Da brauchen die einen Heli, weil wie sollen die sonst aufs Dach kommen?
Richtig.
Also das ist, das ist One-Head.
One-Head.
Also Two-Head, Three-Head ist da noch zu wenig für.
Das ist nicht vorhanden-Head.
Fuck, hätte da funktionieren können.
Null-Head ist das.
No-Head, genau, nicht No-Pet, No-Head.
No-Pet, No-Head.
Just take the Objective, Leute, Just take the Objective, das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein.
Just Objective-Taggen, Mann.
Wo ist das Problem?
Okay Leute, eine Runde machen wir noch.
Custom-Server.
Also, es gibt ja aktuell gar keine Server.
Aber wenn, dann mache ich irgendwas mit bisschen Five-Head-Portal-Rules-Editor.
Kann man wieder in Portal XP farmen, kann sich offizielle Rush-Playlist spielen, das
geht.
Warum das nicht unter All-Out-Warfare steht, verstehe ich übrigens auch nicht.
Ich meine, das ist mehr Battlefield-Warfare als der Rest.
Okay, spielen wir noch eine Runde Breakaway, dann ist gut.
Haben die jetzt eigentlich wirklich den Boris und Webster-Skin entfernt oder sehe ich es
bloß nicht?
Zwei Helis und M-Kommer auf dem Dach, keck weh.
Okay, Game, laden, please.
Ach, die Skins sollten nicht sichtbar sein, aah.
Wo sehe ich denn die Weekly-Aufgaben, das gucken wir uns gleich mal an, wo man das sieht.
Wie alt ist Max eigentlich, viel zu alt, ich bin 37.
Ich kann wieder nicht aussteigen, warum ist das so verbaggt, ach, die Weeklys sind noch
gar nicht drinnen.
Okay, wir überrennen die gerade richtig, vielleicht doch noch zwei Runden, keine Ahnung.
Ich schätze dich, Massive Rats stellt es, aah, oh, knapp, knapp, wenn der Kram ja alles
ein bisschen schneller gehen würde und man könnte ordentlich moveen, stellt euch mal
vor, man könnte seinen Defi aufladen und dann hingehen, reviven und wieder zurück.
Es soll ja schon mal Spiele gegeben haben, da ging sowas.
Boah, da unten sind 50 Milliarden Gegner, okay, da ist wirklich viel los und hier kommt
bestimmt gleich irgendwas rauf und ich werde nicht in die richtige Richtung gucken, ich
sage es euch, ich weiß schon, ich gucke bestimmt in die falsche Richtung klar, okay, ja klar
Boris, alles klar Boris, das hast du überlebt.
Pass auf, der kommt jetzt von hinten und will mich Gatschi-bassen, gibt es aber nichts,
wenn ihr einen Gatschi bastet, dann ich, okay, oder auch nicht, ich dachte eigentlich mit
der MP9 im Nahkampf reinbrettern, Overwatch-Beta-Zeit, ja Overwatch-Beta war das beste, Overwatch-Beta
war Massive-Pog, aber richtig Pog, ich finde fast, in der Beta hat Overwatch am meisten
Spaß gemacht.
Kommt rein, kommt rein, kommt rein, auf, move, ne.
Wow, 50 Milliarden Gegner, das war ein Konsolenspieler, wahrscheinlich, der Typ hinter mir meinste,
ja wahrscheinlich war es ein Konsolenspieler, oder der mich auto-aimt hat.
Max-MW2-Gameplay, da war es aber richtig früh, weil so richtig, so richtig Abos bekommen
habe ich ja erst mit Black Ops, also wer MW2 am Start war, der war wirklich sehr früh
dabei, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh nein, Angel did it again, der war wirklich richtig früh
dabei mit MW2, Alter, was ist das hier, Hayabiner, Hayabiner, ne, das war Black Ops 2, oder?
Warte mal, Leute, war das Black Ops 2 oder MW2, oh, jetzt geht es ab, Tommy, vielen Dank
eschön für die 5 gegifteten Subs, wer hat denn hier gedodged, der hält die Hälfte
des Chats hat gedodged, PrimeSky hat was bekommen, EpicLunch, Varian, Frexor, Dosenbier, huge,
ne, ne, ne, Bo1, das war Bo2, Hayabiner, Hayabiner, das war Bo2, MW2 war Tango Sucker,
huge melee kill, habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, wie kacke die Animation ist, die ist doch
richtig reudig, oder, jetzt war ehrlich, Mann, Kugel, geht mal rein, der Ultraskiller, ja,
der ist da, kaum ist der Serious Max weg, läuft es nicht, das cute Squad muss komplett sein,
sonst wird das nix, du hast ein Video mit Commander Krieger gemacht, ich hab mit relativ
vielen damals ein Video gemacht, was für mich hart anstrengend war, weil ich nicht
gern mit anderen Leuten rede eigentlich, glaubt man gar nicht, aber ist so, boah ey, okay,
wir müssen das anders machen, so funktioniert das nicht, so funktioniert das nicht, guckt
euch das mal an hier, 4-4, das morgen dämmerer Squad ist nur 8er anstatt 1er, das geht nicht,
das geht nicht, Belfil jetzt gefixt, nö, das einzige gute ist 16 vs. 16, ist nicht
mehr so clusterfuck und deswegen halbwegs spielbar, okay, vielleicht können wir krasse
Flankerino machen, ja, klar, klar, klar, klau da mit dem Kill, au, der ist grad perfekt,
wow, alter, was ist denn hier los, du machst irgendwie Flank Action und das ist ja fast
schon wie 64 vs. 64, obwohl es nur 16 vs. 16 ist, wir haben es gelegt, lege Henne, nice,
der Fatal hat es geläscht, jetzt müssen wir nur noch Defenden, was relativ einfach geht,
weil ich das Gefühl hab, das M-Com, oh, ich sag's noch, ich sag's noch, normalerweise
finde ich, ist das Defenden tatsächlich einfacher, also hier, das M-Com Defenden, wenn du mal
gelegt hast, ist jetzt wieder ESL Lobby angesagt, zwischendurch, zum Glück kam man ein Stückchen
weg, die lasern gut rein, ich will mal kurz aufs Dach gucken, das Auto ist am Start, ernsthaft
jetzt, ernsthaft, ja, der hat nur darauf gewartet, dass da einer um die Ecke kommt, um da mit
seinem komischen RPG-Ding rein zu hauen, aber es gibt keinen Sensorgranaten-Nerf, ne, leider,
ich finde die Dinger auch viel zu OP, ehrlich gesagt, du denkst, dass ich den nicht gesehen
hab, oder? Okay, also, das ist echt das Camper-Zelt überhaupt, okay, was heißt Camper, das sind
Defender, was sollen sie machen, ja, was sollen sie machen, okay Leute, richtig nicer Stream
heute, endlich hat das Game einen Modus, den man spielen kann, ohne permanent übertrieben
krass abzuragen, die Sache ist halt die, im Kern sind die Probleme, vor allem die Maps,
immer noch offensichtlich und da, und ich sag euch wie es ist, Rush wird auch, wenn
es in der Form bleibt, langweilig, werden nach 1-2 Wochen, Moment, was, Rush wird es
nur eine Woche geben, wie jetzt, wie, also wenn die wirklich Rush rausnehmen, dann sind
sie noch dümmer als ich, als ich, ist es limited, sind die von allen guten Geistern
verlassen oder was, ernsthaft, die einzige Kacke, die du in diesem Spiel erträglich
spielen kannst, ist limited oder was, meine Güte, das kann, das sollte sich in dein Herz,
hängen geblieben, ich sei jetzt richtig hängen geblieben, wenn das echt so ist, BF200 Rush
limited time, oops, ich hab BF3 eingeben, BF2042, jaja, ne, das, die hätten die sich
die Leute schon aufgeregt drüber, wenn das der Fall wäre, das ist bestimmt debated,
der Chat hat bestimmt debated, das ist bestimmt doch nicht limited, geh nochmal zurück, das
hast du davor, oder meinst du hier die Patchnodes, ne, erstes Google Ergebnis, äh, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ja, ne, keine Ahnung, okay Leute, keine Ahnung, ich gehe jetzt, Bettke, wir sehen uns, guck
mal ganz schnell, ob ich noch irgendjemand hosten kann, mal ein kleines, der das braucht.
Okay Leute wir sehen uns bis denn, see you, bis morgen wahrscheinlich gucken wir mal
bis denn, machts gut.